so da bin ich am start leute heute letzter stream zum thema access point web interface
modden ich denke mal das ist dann irgendwann auch mal fertig es ist ja eigentlich schon
fertig und es funktioniert ja eigentlich auch schon aber ich habe mir gedacht wir machen
das mal anstatt vanilla javascript mal etwas ordentlicher mit svelte und vielleicht sogar
typescript dabei bin ich ganz sicher könnt ihr euch dann aussuchen mach schon mal bis bis
das stream richtig losgeht werde ich mal die vm runde updaten weil arch by the way rolling
release muss geupdatet werden alter wie mir das auf den sack geht vmw alle geben nerv nicht
lasst mich in ruhe ich will kein update machen weil ich habe gelesen dass es mit dem 17.01
wohl irgendwelche probleme gibt in vmw ich habe leider schon wieder verdrängt was es
eigentlich genau gewesen ist ich glaube es gab wieder input lag unter linux nee nee nee
netzwerk netzwerk connection probleme gab es mit 17.01 habe ich gelesen deswegen habe ich
noch nicht geupgraded so ich mache mal update bis das stream richtig angelaufen ist da müssen
wir eigentlich gar nicht restoren alles haben cooles projekt gefunden zeige ich euch gleich
nein nein ich muss kein tmax mehr starten gibt überhaupt keinen sinn tmax zu starten
kann mit meinem terminal alles machen auch kein tmax mehr
erstmal das wichtigste programm überhaupt öffnen packen update eine runde gibt jeden
tag updates und war da kerner dabei nicht eben ging ein bisschen ging ein bisschen schnell
für kerner da müssen wir nicht ruhen kein reboot required
auch in der drei stunden bis das gepackaged ist wunderbar alles klar so wir haben geupdated
wir gehen hier mal repos wir machen da was neues auf scripts ne in kardier nennen wir
erstmal user scripts so ich habe nämlich ein cooles projekt gefunden zeige ich euch
gleich was zu oh ich muss den access point einschalten damit wir jetzt ordentlich ordentlich
basteln können seck das sollte ich jetzt vielleicht mal machen bevor wir anfangen so switch ein
switch sollte ich warte mal bis der switch gebudet ist und dann mache ich den access
point ran weil ohne access point wird das ganze natürlich nix wir können schlecht das
web interface vom access point modifizieren ohne dass der access point angeschaltet ist
alles klar ping oh der ist noch nicht an muss man schnell gucken das machen wir alles bevor
das stream richtig angelaufen ist mal gucken was der für eine dhcp adresse kriegt dieses
haben wir hier hundert und 148 vielleicht das sein nee das ist es eher nicht würde
ich sagen engine x proxy manager was ist denn wo ist denn das switch
unleashed oder denn mein ok der esses das ding das ding ändert auch random random die
ip oder wie es gerade bock hat na gut ok so als weiß ich übrigens was mein access point
für eine ip hat dann können wir anfangen ich zeige euch gleich wo wir stehen geblieben
sind das letzte mal für alle die nicht dabei waren die musik ist nervig ist die zu laut
mit die mega catchy zu catch ja mal abfahren wenn man dann proga stels anmachen dann mache
ich irgendwas entspanntes an so ist das ding jetzt mal gestartet dachte das verdammte spiel
und ich will ich back advanced except ich excepte ich excepte das risk risk excepted atmen save
wir alles ok dann zeige ich mal kurz wo wir stehen geblieben sind nur kurz die ip updaten
1 2 1 vielleicht auch richtig updaten dann gehts auch ok nice ist klar sehr schön ok
dann können wir ein bisschen was entspannteres anmachen ist wahrscheinlich besser klassiker
die klar die playlist ist glaube ich eines der ersten playlists die ich je im stream
aufgemacht habe ja öfters mal was neues modge pay to win modge
was sind das für komische musik empfehlung hier also die playlist ist irgendwie nicht
so ganz deckt sich nicht so ganz mit dem was empfohlen wird gut ich meine wie funktioniert
eine spülmaschine finde ich tatsächlich auch interessant dass das würde ich sogar
glatt gucken wie funktioniert eine spülmaschine was letzte preis letzte preis bei ebay war
das ist die freige da habe ich darauf gewartet ja ich zeige euch jetzt wo wir stehen geblieben
das letzte mal und zwar das ist das web interface von meinem access point und es gibt hier so ein
menü zum passwörter generieren da wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt aber richtig klicken kann da und
da gibt es ein button add so und hier kann man jetzt einen neuen user hinzufügen ja create
ist der neue user da das sieht jetzt alles so aus als ist so standardmäßig mit dabei ist es aber
nicht dieser button und dieses pop-up und dieses random password generieren ist von mir ist nicht
standardmäßig mit dabei wenn ich das ausschalte custom scripts 9x fanatics wenn ich das aus schalte
das custom script hier dann ist da nämlich kein button wie du siehst hier da guck das ist weg
sind aus kali 14 ja gut dann ist es also das ist doch die amis schuld so und das letzte mal
sind wir stehen geblieben bei folgendem dynamic sind wir bei folgendem stehen geblieben und zwar
also vielleicht vielleicht fange ich noch mal ganz kurz so fünf minuten warum wir das ganze
überhaupt machen also ich benutze also ich habe früher unify access points benutzt da hatte ich
zum beispiel so so ein unify access point dann hatte ich ein nano hd von unify und auch irgendwie
die kleinere variante davon die habe ich jetzt seit einer weile rausgeschmissen die unify access
points und hab die ersetzt allerdings natürlich nicht ohne grund und hab die ersetzt durch durch
so ein bzw. durch zwei das ist die etwas ältere generation preislich ungefähr auf ebay hat das
gleiche gebraucht wie unify neu ich habe den r510 den r610 und r710 und warum habe ich unify
ausgetauscht dagegen ganz einfach weil ich features vermisst habe bei unify und ich habe
ein feature im speziellen vermisst nämlich dass man mehrere password haben kann für das gleiche
wlan das geht normalerweise nicht normalerweise also psk ist das wlan password steht für pre
shared key das ist das was man normalerweise eingibt wenn man sein iphone connecten will zu
einem wlan dann muss man password eingeben so und unify kann das nicht also unify ist nicht in der
lage mehrere passwörter für die gleiche ssid beziehungsweise für das gleiche wlan festzulegen
da gibt es gibt es schon zig feature requests bei ubiquity und die interessieren sich dafür
überhaupt nicht guck hier das ist also selbst auf reddit bla bla bla bla bla das stimmt überhaupt
nicht das sind einfach das sind solche dumm schwätzer das sind das stimmt doch gar nicht
das ist guck dir mal an was die leute wieder für einen absoluten bullshit schreiben und dann
auch abgewartet wird das stimmt schlicht und ergreifend nicht jeder große hersteller hat
dieses feature mittlerweile das heißt dann zwar nicht dpsk sondern das heißt mpsk oder mdpsk oder
was auch immer aber dieses feature hat ist das wirklich absolute pepega shit wieder auf reddit
irgendwelche leute die denken sie hatten voll den krassen den krassen plan absolut kein kein
hau ja die haben auf sicherlich auf dieses feature in patent allerdings muss man sich
letztes mal durchlesen aber wahrscheinlich nicht auf die implementierung mehrere password
fürs wlan das ist schwierig so was zu patent patentieren wahrscheinlich nur in kombination
mit dass es dynamisch also dass es dpsk heißt und im irgendwelchen speziellen features die
die sich am patentieren lassen und außerdem bei den amis ist es ja so die amis patentieren
sich alles ja da kannst du sogar wenn du wenn du wenn du wenn du socken herstellt der rot
gestreift es kann sogar rot gestreiften socken patentieren lassen die machen das anders die
machen nur so ganz minimal plausibilitätscheck lego dankeschön für den zapp ganz ganz simple
plausibilitätscheck und dann wird das ganze patentiert und wenn dann irgendjemand sein patent
durchsetzen will oder dagegen will oder was auch immer dann verklagen die sich halt drei
jahre lang so machen die amis das halt das ist blödsinn dieses feature hat auch wenn der typ
hier was anderes schreibt dieses feature hat jeder größere hersteller das hat sag ich
gleich was zu ruckus oder ruckus hat das aruba hat das miraki hat das cisco hat wobei ist
cisco nicht mehr ich glaube es gibt glaube die haben sich gekauft hat das soforz haben
wir nachgeguckt glaube ich auch open wrt kanns mittlerweile sogar links ist kanns diese omada
dinger können dass es mikrotik kanns mittlerweile auch es kann im prinzip so gut wie jeder hersteller
die einzigen die das nicht können die einzigen die das nicht können ist also billig access
points ja von amazon für 20 euro aber selbst die mikrotik dinger können aber die mikrotik
dinger sind wieder wie üblich bis in wir zu konfigurieren das können sie das können
sie mehr oder weniger alle aber reddit ist der meinung nein das können die nicht dann
gut wenn reddit das sagt wie gesagt feature requests und anfragen gibt es total viele
seit 2016 guckt das ist beispielsweise hier was ganz neues und das gibt hier von vor
zwei jahren unsere ewig ewig lange diskussionen und daumenhoch aber ganz ehrlich ubiquity juckt
das ganze nicht guck mal hier sogar von 2017 gibt es hier schon was wie heißt das in open
wrt ppsk glaube ich kann das sein open wrt wifi mode ja support hier das da aber das
von 2018 ich habe es gibt ein github issue dazu es gibt ein github issue dazu da habe
ich nämlich drüber gefunden ja ne moment luci oder lucy ist ja nur das web interface
von open wrt na gut wir könnten danach suchen weil open wrt verwendet intern ja ap d ne
wie heißt das wie heißt das ding was open wrt intern verwendet das gibt es ja auch
für linux haust ap haust ap d ja genau das meine ich da muss man mal gucken multi multi
ppsk anscheinend ulti ppsk ppsk radios radios ist blödsinn mit radios kann ja jeder
hier pull request aus ppsk heißt das ganze wohl bei open wrt so ping ping
da war es wie viel wie viel aber hier hier ist es ja private ppsk ppsk muss zu suchen
das gibt es mittlerweile gibt seit letztem Mitte letzten jahres gibt es das in open wrt
hier option ppsk eins was radios ok das geht wohl auch über den radioserver anscheinend
machen die es nicht intern na gut das ist ja letztendlich egal es ist in dem fall nicht
wpr enterprise die kriegen nur den key von einem radioserver wobei man kann auch bestimmt
in den bild in radioserver nehmen aber muss man sagen die haben das wieder ganz gut ganz
gut dokumentiert man plickt halbwegs durch was man machen muss also ppsk nennt das ganze
in in open wrt allerdings wie dem auch sei open wrt das gucken wir uns ja demnächst an
demnächst flaschen wir das auf einen meiner alten unify access points und da bin ich mal
gespannt wie das wie das ganze laufen wird ja aber um darauf einzugehen wozu wozu ist
recht einfach zu erklären wenn du ein wlan gerät wegschmeißt also das ist glaube ich
das offensichtlichste und einleuchtendste beispiel jetzt natürlich noch mehrere feinere
varianten wofür das verwenden kannst ja aber das einfachste beispiel ist du hast ein gerät
das in deinem wlan hängt so das geht kaputt und du schmeißt es weg dann liegt ja im prinzip
dein wlan credentials also dein wlan login und dein wlan password deine wlan credentials
liegen im müll das heißt jeder könnte das von dem ehem von dem jeweiligen gerät recover
wenn er die zeit und energie reinstecken will also du wirfst ein tablet weg vielleicht
geht es nicht mehr an du kannst es nicht flaschen mehr vorher also kannst du nicht mehr resetten
liegen deine wlan credentials im müll du hast irgendeine wlan klübierne die wirfst du
in müll weil sie kaputt ist irgendjemand hat eine wlan credentials wenn er die klübierne
herausfischt und wieder einschaltet und ausliest oder aber du hast irgendwelche gäste bei dir
im leute die keine ahnung bei dir mal zu besuch kommen den gibts dein wlan password und dann
willst du dass der halt später nicht mehr reinkommt dann müsstest du ja theoretisch
überall ein wlan password ändern ja ich weiß natürlich sagen die leute jetzt wieder ja
man kann das über einen portal mit voucher machen man kann in gäste wlan machen ja ja
das ist aber das ist aber am eigentlichen problem dran rum gedockt dort ich glaube wenn
man sich den fall überlegt man schmeißt was in müll wo die wlan credentials noch drauf
sind das ist glaube ich so das beste beispiel mini dankeschön für den sub so und wenn du
das nicht willst dann musst du jedem gerät ein eigenes wlan password geben du könntest
natürlich auch für jedes gerät ein eigenes wlan aufmachen das wäre natürlich ein bisschen
overkill also das macht dein empfang schlechter weil du immer mehr ssids broadcastest die
meisten access points können maximal vier wlan ssids oder vier oder acht wlan ssids
gleichzeitig als es funktioniert nicht theoretisch geht das praktisch ist es nicht praktikabel
120 ssids aufzumachen für jedes gerät eine so und wenn du für ein wlan mehrere passwörter
haben kannst da kannst du ein gerät wegschmeißen also zum beispiel ich zeige ich zeige dir
das jetzt mal hier wie das funktioniert also ich habe hier ich habe hier den wlan guck
da wifi network test wlan heißt das ganze übrigens disabel falls ich heute wieder passwörter
liege leute ihr müsst nicht klippen oder sonst was die passwörter bringen nix das
ist ein access point den habe ich nur zum rumspielen der wird nicht verwenden das wlan
ist eh aus so und mein wlan hat natürlich ein master password wenn ich das master password
eingebe ist das wie mit jedem anderen wlan ich komme rein ich kann allerdings auch jetzt
hier zum beispiel sagen ich will jetzt hier kilted iphone kann ich jetzt anlegen mit einem
random password oder mit einem tackle aiaia 123 bla bla bla password kann ich jetzt anlegen
create und dann gibt es jetzt für dein iphone habe ich jetzt ihren eigenen user mit einem
eigenen password für dieses wlan angelegt das heißt du könntest jetzt ganz normal
in das wlan rein mit deinem iphone dann wird die mac adresse gelockt das nur noch dieses
gerät also nach dem ersten anmelden das nur noch dieses gerät mit dieser mac nach dem
ersten mal einloggen dann in zukunft weiter sich einloggen darf und dann kannst du so
lange wie du willst bei mir im wlan rum wlanen und wenn ich dich irgendwann rausschmeißen
will dann lösche ich dich hier einfach wieder so und das schöne ist alle anderen geräte
die verbunden sind behalten ihr password die muss ich nicht ändern aber du kannst nicht
mehr rein in dem moment wo ich dir auf löschen klick was ist schon sehr praktisch es ist
gerade für iot geräte praktisch weil andere geräte könntest du wpr enterprise mit radio
server machen wurde dann wirklich user und password und so was eingeben muss allerdings
es gibt zu also ganz ganz selten dass das mal ein iot gerät unterstützt 99 prozent
alle iot geräte können kein wpr enterprise wenn sie es könnten hat es der hersteller
in seiner firme nicht usable gemacht ich glaube das sind erst ich glaube in esp 32 mit dem
standard standard stk ich glaube die haben sogar wpr enterprise support drinne aber kein
hersteller baut es nutzbar ein ja so funktioniert das und wenn du beispielsweise ein admin bist
und das stelle ich mal vor du bist ein admin auf irgendeiner messe und du musst zugänge
generieren dann kannst du es ja auch relativ easy machen sagst du ich brauche 15 user und
die sollen aber bitteschön in wlan 5 in wlan 5 dann hast du hier zack generate und auf
einen schlag hast du 15 15 user die du danach wieder löschen kannst und niemand kommt mehr
in das wlan also ist schon ist schon ein äußerst praktisches feature kann man nichts dagegen
sagen montag 16 uhr komm aus komme aus komme aus den feierabend und denke mir
warum du nicht aber dann bis 16 uhr arbeite ich eigentlich nie also bis 16 uhr 30 arbeite
ich nie und montags arbeite ich prinzipiell nicht im hotel genau im hotel ist das auch
sehr sinnvoll ich persönlich finde das hier ist ein viel besseres feature als diese voucher
kacke mit dich erstmal an einem proxy anmelden oder identifizieren und sonst was ich finde
das finde das viel praktischer oder aber wie die ganzen kleinen hotels das teilweise machen
die haben irgendwo eine fritzbox stehen und geben die halt das password für ihr wlan
das heißt du musst dann einfach nur dich neben das hotel stellen und ganz ins wlan
für immer bis sie irgendwann mal keine ahnung nach einem jahr das password ändern oder
so falls überhaupt jemals das ganze passiert also das ist ja praktisch das coole ist das
coole ist also ich zeige euch mal wir machen jetzt mal wir legen jetzt mal hier den user
hier den omega omega lull user legen wir an und man könnte zum beispiel auch ein qr code
ausdrucken lassen und das den leuten dann in die hand drücken also ihr könnt ihr könnt
es ausprobieren ihr könnt es jetzt ihr könnt es jetzt einscannen vom bildschirm ich meine
ihr seid nicht in reichweite von meinem wlan und mein wlan ist aus aber nur nur von der
ideen das funkt das würde funktionieren also jedes x beliebige aktuelle smartphone kann
das wenn ihr diesen qr code einscannen wie gesagt wenn ihr wollt probiert es aus ihr
könnt den qr code einscannen und dann fragt er euch ob ihr zu testwlan connecten wollt
das heißt ihr müsst dann kein password mehr eingeben oder sowas also kannst es den leuten
einfach hier ausdrucken und zack auf geht's man kann das ganze auch expiren lassen das
funktioniert auch und man kann sogar mehrere geräte dafür erlauben also sprich man könnte
zum beispiel sagen hey die meisten leute haben vielleicht ein smartphone und ein tablet dann
dann sagst du halt einfach mal okay die dürfen sich das ganze über zwei geräte sharen das
sie halt oder notebook ja sagst du sagst du tablet smartphone notebook jeder user kriegt drei geräte
oder so und trotzdem sobald der typ auschecked kannst du wieder löschen und du kannst auch
expiren lassen irgendwie das ist aber die die expires des expires setting ist glaube ich
irgendwo irgendwo anders wo man das wo man das angeben kann man kann das man kann das
auch expiren lassen nach einer nach zwei tagen oder sowas das also das finde ich persönlich
viel viel besser geeignet für beispielsweise ein hotel als dieses dieses mit mit portal
web proxy freischalten und voucher geschiss und sowas kann halt nicht jeder jeder billig
access point die guten können es eigentlich mehr oder weniger alle es sei denn die leute
verwenden unify unify denkt sich nämlich beziehungsweise ubiquity denkt sich nämlich nö da haben wir
keinen bock drauf das overrated outdated gbated gachirol das brauchen wir nicht ich glaube
das hat sich echt so ein manager gedacht also wortwörtlich quote das war bestimmt exakt
der gedankengang von irgendeinem ubiquity manager hat es gedacht weird champ gachirol
wir implementieren das nicht genauso in dieser reinfolge so und das was ich euch jetzt hier
gezeigt habe mit dem anlegen von diesem user das ist ein custom dialog von mir den habe
ich eingebaut in das web interface und da machen wir heute ein bisschen dran weiter
allerdings also ich will ja noch ein paar kleine kleine sachen einbauen ja zum beispiel dass
man das dass man passwort random eisen kann auf drei verschiedene arten so nach dem motto
wörter wörter komplett random oder nur zahlen oder sowas ist ja manchmal ganz praktisch
denn du hast den mikrotik access point bestellt das ist kein mikrotik access point hier
deswegen ok ja wie gesagt mikrotik kann das auch wobei ganz ehrlich die mikrotik implementierung
davon ist etwas weird champ dafür sind die dinger billig ich weiß nicht ob du mit der
mikrotik variante so so glücklich wirst aber die können also ich weiß dass sie das können
aber ich habe keine ahnung ob mikrotik alles davon kann könnten wir gleich ein passwort
generator bauen da habe ich vorhin bei mir abgeschaut komplett ein passwort generator
wir haben ja ein passwort generator schon wir haben passwort generator der kann ich jetzt
zeigen hier ein passwort generator der macht sowas hier das habe ich von stack overflow
copy pasted stack overflow driven security das habe ich von stack overflow gepastet ich
weiß nicht ob das gut ist oder nicht gut also ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ihr wisst
dass ich mikrotik wirklich gerne mag was netzwerkequipment angeht also ich habe jede menge mikrotik switcher
mikrotik router aber ich muss sagen die mikrotik access points die sind nicht so wirklich mein
fall also da habe ich jetzt bisher nicht so viel freude dran also ne was heißt ich hatte
ich hatte ja nie einen mikrotik access point hier großartig im einsatz aber das hat mir
nie großartig zugesagt beste gpu für 800 keine ahnung ich habe wirklich keinen plan
ich habe einfach viel zu viel geld ausgegeben im december für neuen rechner bei dem ich
mir sicher war der hält jetzt eine weile wo wir gerade beim thema sind leute leute modge
mod mod check mod mod check jemand am start
mod check könnten wir ein kommando einfügen oder updaten für meinen pc mit diesem link
aus meiner twitter bio weil ich habe einen link auf geizhals gesetzt und es ist wichtig
es ist wichtig dass es dieser link ist weil euch fällt vielleicht auf dass es ein geizhals
ref link die sind leider ein bisschen spät die sind leider ein bisschen spät gewesen
nachdem ich mein rechnervideo hochgeladen habe haben die gesagt max wollen wir nicht
wollen wir nicht ref link programm machen aber ich sag doch machen wir ich verlinke
eh ganz ganz gerne geizhals allerdings jetzt ist ja das meiste schon durch aber das ist
ein geizhals linker und den können wir da rein machen genau ausrufezeichen pc und und
dafür den link von den da gh.de irgendetwas oder den da kannst du auch direkt den da nehmen
den auf den er auflöst ok ne ne ne ne nicht wobei gruppier mal lieber den ja twitter ist richtig
dumm twitter ist richtig dumm copy paste einfach mit control c das sollte auch gehen ja die
sind tatsächlich die können das übrigens auch die können auch dynamische wlan passwörter
pro user ja ja also ich finde unify gerät aktuell so ein bisschen ins hintertreffen
zumal ich schon seit anfang an bei unify so ein bisschen immer so des den eindruck hatte
die wissen nicht genau an wen sie sich richten wollen auf der einen seite ist es zu undurchsichtig
und auf der anderen seite hat es zu wenig features also je nachdem für was ich weiß nicht also
ich ich war nie so hundertprozentig glücklich mit unify da sind die dinger hier sind mir
deutlich lieber so genau also guckt hier mal also wir generieren ja schon random random
passwörter aktuell allerdings ich wollte euch ja zeigen was ich für ein projekt gefunden
habe kommen wir mal kommen wir mal zu der eigentlichen geschichte zurück und zwar wir
haben hier ein user script erstellt was sich in die webseite einklingt und diesen button
hierhin baut den da und dieses dieses popup macht das ist alles zwar recht gut lesbar
aber es ist alles vanilla javascript wie die amis immer so schön sagen javascript
es ist recht gut lesbar aber es ist jetzt auch nicht das aller allerbeste vor allem
nicht das allerbeste zu erweitern deswegen habe ich mal ein bisschen auf github rumgeguckt
und ich habe ein projekt gefunden das genau richtig ist für das was wir machen wollen
es gibt nämlich das da hat auch hat auch 482 sterne ist eigentlich ganz nice das ist genau
dafür gedacht nur dass es bessere templates hat als was die offizielle seite vorschlägt
also sprich damit kann man jusascript erstellen inklusive hot reload für die seite was natürlich
auch schon mal praktisch ist man kann jusascript erstellen also jusascript sind quasi das die
schon bestehende seiten verändern und modden können und man hat die auswahl ob man das
ganz in view react was ist eigentlich preact react was ist was ist preact fast 3 kilobyte
react alternative ok preact ich dachte dass solid js das neue minimal react ist ist es
jetzt ist es jetzt preact oder solid oder oder was ist denn jetzt das geilere man blickt
da nicht so genau durch zumindest und das ist das worauf ich so ein bisschen geschielt
habe ist die haben auch svelte support und das machen wir heute denn das coole an svelte
ist dass es ja quasi ein framework less framework ist ich weiß gar nicht was sie selber zu
sich sagen also svelte ist ja was was nachdem du es nachdem du es gebaut hast in der eigentlichen
anwendung nicht mehr vorhanden ist also es ist nicht wie view oder oder react oder sowas
mit mit mit runtime komponenten svelte ist quasi nur zur compile zeit also verschwindet
zur compile zeit und verschwindet zu ganz normalen javascript das heißt das kommt dann
auch nicht in die quere irgendwie mit allem möglichen anderem zeug was vielleicht drauf
läuft weil ich könnte ich könnte mir vorstellen dass wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel react app
anlege und ich weiß dieses interface von denen hier dieses web interface vom access point
das ist selbst mit react gebaut da kann ich mir vorstellen kommt sich das eventuell bei
manchen sachen in die quere sind diese skripte nur ausgebunden das kommt darauf an was du
reinschreibst auf was es gelten soll du kannst es mit wildcard machen du kannst es auf mehreren
seiten laufen lassen du kannst es aber auch explizit einstellen dass es nur auf einer
seite läuft dachte das ist immer so zumindest die frontend seite sehe dass es mit react
gebaut ist sind doch ja bin ich sicher bin ich sicher pass mal auf ich weiß nicht ob
man es im source code sieht und und natürlich dann noch bei aglify js was zum teufel ist
aglify js wie viele javascript sachen gibt es eigentlich von denen man noch nie was gehört
hat und einfach 12.000 github sterne das das frontend javascript irkosystem macht mich
fertig leute aglify js alles klar und was ist es aglify javascript parser minifier compressor
und beautifier ja wie jetzt ich denke es ist aglifier leute ich blick bei der ganzen frontend
geschichte nicht mehr durch das ist mir das ist mir alles zu hoch was es da gibt ja achso
ja ja also ne ne ne ne die müssen nicht an jedem admin pits also wenn du sie verwenden
willst dann müssen sie im jeweiligen browser installiert sein du kannst die dinger wahrscheinlich
irgendwie sünken wenn du deine browser sünken willst aber ja so ist das also die werden
nicht vom access point ausgeliefert jetzt kurz was gucken vor einem handy sekunde das
poc phone ja sag ich so sieht es heute aus ok passt alles ok auf geht's ich würde sagen
dann fangen wir mal an weird flex ich flexe einzig und alleine aus dem grund weil ich
festgestellt habe 1500 euro im stream titel das kommt gut ab ach du warst das hättest
du vorher mal geschrieben dann hätte ich ja auch gesehen du bist nur hier ja ja man
muss man muss jetzt 1500 euro access points donaten dann wird man motge easy so also dann
machen wir das mal weg ich zeige euch jetzt mal weiß ich was ich hier entdeckt habe auf
jithub und zwar also aktuell hat man user user scripts folgendermaßen erstellt man
ist hier hingegangen auf edit und hat dann hier den kram editiert so das ist im browser
nicht sonderlich schön man konnte das ganze auch über den umweg in visual studio code
editieren aber das hat er nicht richtig reloaded und sonst war alles nicht so schön im prinzip
hat man hier editiert und dann hier reloaded und geguckt ob es funktioniert aber ich hab
das ja im vorfall schon ein bisschen mir ein bisschen angeguckt es war mal create monkey
kann ja nicht schief gehen was soll da schon schief gehen ich mein klingt absolut vertrauenswürdig
so was auszuführen ich bin übrigens immer wieder erstaunt die jungs bei javascript die
haben einen hang dazu blind sachen aus dem internet auszuführen du musst nichts dazu
installieren du führst einfach den befehl aus und irgendwie es läuft das heißt da
muss im hintergrund erstmal das halbe internet runterladen damit du das ausführen kannst
also die javascript beziehungsweise frontend leute haben generell einen gewissen hang dazu
sachen blind aus dem internet runter zu laden auszuführen das ist das heißt jetzt ja unter
der haube wird das hier wahrscheinlich auch npx verwenden ok select the framework use
arrow keys wir wollen svelte und jetzt dürft ihr euch aussuchen leute typescript mal zur
abwechslung ihr wisst ich habe nicht viel nicht viel plan von typescript ich würde
ich würde typescript an der stelle einfach nur verwenden dass mein autocomplete ein
bisschen besser ist ich würde ich werde wahrscheinlich nicht viel mit typescript in dem sinn jetzt
hier auseinandersetzen typescript beste ok typescript was ist tailwind schon wieder
tailwind meinst du ich habe gedacht es gibt jetzt tailwind so eine minimal so eine minimal
variante von von tailwind wobei eine minimal variante von tailwind css gibt es ja auch
schon windy css oder sowas ich sage euch ohne missleute frontend es vergeht keine sekunde
ohne neue java script frameworks typescript cd pnpm install ok erstmal schwarzes loch
auf der festplatte erzeugen das ging ja richtig schnell was ist da los ich mein der hat der
hat nur 107 packages installiert das ist jetzt aber schwach das ist aber ganz schwach
ich finde das sollte schon ein bisschen mehr sein dürfen ich meine es sind nur 106 mb
source code 106 mb das ist ok das ist nicht das halbe internet aber ok normale normale
projekte haben wahrscheinlich 800 mb source code aber 106 mb wir reden ja nicht von irgendwelchen
fertigen binaries das ist 106 mb einfach source codes boilerplate shit und npm modules ok
also erstmal editor öffnen 106 mb text also könnt ihr vorstellen das ist schon ein bisschen
was ok ich kopiere mir das mal an die zwischenablage hier und machen wir rüber das an browser ok
das alte script machen wir mal aus und jetzt muss ich machen was npm was war es npm run
oder oder was oder wie an dem moment ascii aquarium kann man zu npm run def npm run def
alles klar so jetzt kopieren wir das da rein und jetzt wird man schon sehen gleich dass
das deutlich besser ist beziehungsweise eine eine nicere development experience als die
alte variante man macht den lokalen server auf der erkennt sofort dass das in addon browser
extension script ist pnpm was ist das denn wieder für neue hipster scheiß das ist gar
nicht mehr so neu pnpm ist quasi npm nur dass das sim links verwendet anstatt alles
immer neu runterzuladen dementsprechend ist es viel schneller und braucht viel weniger
speicherplatz also wahrscheinlich ist glaube ich npm schon fast neues neues meta mittlerweile
oder es gibt wieder was neues was schon an mir vorbei gegangen ist gucken wir doch mal
pnpm versus npm versus jan versus ich glaube pnpm ist immer noch angesagt hast kein geld
mehr für festplatten so 22.000 22.000 ja hast du kein geld mehr für festplan ne man muss
ja nicht unnötig den speicherplatz rauskloppen cup no cup in dem fall außerdem wer braucht
festplatten man kann das alles am besten auf eine ram disk machen dann ist npm wenigstens
auch schnell ok also so ich würde vielleicht was auffallen standardmäßig ist dieses template
für google.com also wer schon immer mal google modden wollte als webseite also nur bei sich
lokal kann das machen also ich muss vielleicht erst mal installieren und guckt zack wir haben
wir haben google gemoddet mit einem ultra sinnlosen counter aber wir haben google gemoddet
das schöne ist ja dass das alles kleinseitig ist google bekommt ja davon nix mit anzeige
ist raus ich warte ja drauf dass irgendjemand noch ein fusel fallsystem dafür baut oder
fuse fallsystem dafür baut das ist zwar abverklangsam aber möglich wäre es wobei das gibt es das
gibt es doch bestimmt schon es gibt es doch bestimmt schon wahrscheinlich
das gibt es schon schon guck mal vor fünf jahren gab es da schon youtube fs wundert
mich nicht was geht wird gemacht ganz einfach ich muss mal ich muss mal kurz licht an machen
hier also so sieht er standardmäßig aus jetzt haben wir google so haben wir google gemoddet
wir wollen allerdings nicht google modden wir wollen ja mein access point modden aber
man sieht schon mal dass es funktioniert also sprich wir haben jetzt auf google custom javascript
eingeschleust an der stelle der im kontext dieser seite läuft nur dass wir jetzt komplett
die möglichkeit haben das mit mit mit swell zu machen ich lösche diesen ganzen mist hier
mal da drin steht natürlich weg und jetzt müssen wir erst mal einstellen dass das ganze
für meinen access point gelten soll und nicht für google ich zeige euch mal dass es funktioniert
ja kacke achtung habt es habt es gesehen jetzt steht auf einmal sehr sehr hilfreich hilfreich
in status status messages drauf so aber oder wir können wir ein wir können das moment
ich habe kann ich ich habe kein zwelt addon installiert cringe ist ist das das was man
benutzt leute oder gibt es irgendwelche irgendwelche spezial sachen zwelt was soll ich machen
das moddest du jetzt rein das was ich vorher gezeigt habe nur dass wir es jetzt mit einem
ordentlichen framework machen wo muss das denn hin editor default formatter wo muss
das denn hin link tag geht das überhaupt noch gibt es das überhaupt noch oder ist es
immer noch die predicate aber man sieht sich mal probieren wir mal aus das gibt es glaube
ich nicht mehr was ich noch rein mache button neu das dialog neu und wir bauen noch ein
passportgenerator ein ja so wo war dann mal wie viel fangen wir jetzt da am besten an
ich überlege gerade wie fangen wir jetzt am besten an wir machen wir machen mal einen
pop-up ich will mal ich will das mal mal irgendwas irgendwas sieht ok also wo hängt er denn das
ganze an ihr meint es an body an body hängt er das ganze an ok also sprich wir könnten
mal zum ausprobieren so was hier machen und if style wie geht das jetzt hier fixed position
position fixed mein css man ich will jetzt das overlay was dass man was sieht da funktioniert
das ganze schon mal nicht ok ich kopiere mir das moment ich kopiere mir einfach den anderen
temple rüber das ist das alte script was wir jetzt um was wir jetzt umwurschten wo
haben wir denn hier den ganzen hier guck mal hier ist auch der dieser ganze mist jetzt
kann man doch da jetzt eigentlich schon reinhauen an der stelle position fixed blabla blabla
machen wir das einfach mal an der stelle rein zack boom reload aus irgendwelchen gründen
geht das auch was ist hier los wlans ist noch die feind geht generate password ist noch
die feind ok das verstehe ich null und wlans map ist auch nicht die feind blabla blabla
so jetzt haben wir das popup wieder am start und übrigens falls euch falls euch das nicht
aufgefallen ist an der stelle man hat jetzt live reload guckt mal hier unten auf den button
da steht jetzt create und schreibe jetzt rein null w und ich drücke save im editor und
er instant update das ganze also ich muss jetzt keine reload organ mehr machen hier
drüben und um das um das ordentlich entwickeln zu können da bin ich das letzte mal total
durchgedreht weil das ist das ist äußerst praktisch und vor allem es ist nicht einfach
nur live reload es ist wie ihr seht hot reload der muss die seite nicht neu laden der kann
die einzelnen elemente hier austauschen guckt magic komplett magic
die grills genau so also wir müssen jetzt dieses alte script umbauen in irgendwie paar
hübsche svelts svelte components und sowas wie machen wir das jetzt am besten ich muss
erstmal wieder ein bisschen in den in den svelte mode kommen weil es ist schon ist schon
eine weile her wo ich wo ich das letzte mal wo ich letztes mal svelte gebaut habe es ist
mittlerweile wirklich mein lieblings lieblings frontend framework aber ich schon ich schon
ein bisschen her das ist so eine art browser extension ja so eine art browser extension
ist das es ist quasi eine on the fly generierte browser extensions wenn du wenn du so willst
also es ist eine browser extensions die selbst erweiterbar ist ich glaube das trifft trifft
doch doch das trifft eigentlich genau es ist eine browser extension die du quasi selbst
erweitern kannst und damit alle seiten auf die du drauf gehst potenziell verändern kannst
wenn du willst woran hat sie lesen fragt man sich dann ich überlege gerade wo wir anfangen
leute ich stehe gerade ein bisschen auf dem schlauch ok ich würde sagen wir fangen mit
was ganz simplem an nämlich das geht noch nicht mal zu ok sekunde let show show dialog
also show pop-up oder wie auch immer ist falls das heißt wir machen jetzt hier etwas wie
hidden hidden gleich not ok jetzt ist das ding erstmal wieder weg ich würde sagen wir
fangen mit dem button an das dürfte wahrscheinlich am simpelsten sein hier ist ja kein button
so den button können wir uns von hier klauen nur dass wir das das letzte mal ganz klassisch
mit create element insert element und sonstigen geschichten gemacht haben das heißt wir kopieren
uns das mal bin ich mal gespannt wie wir das hinkriegen das minimieren wir das brauchen
wir nicht sonst ist einfach zu viel so jetzt jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wie wir das wie
wir das zeug übersetzt kriegen in ins weltzeug weil es ist ja so die seite startet ja hier
und hier darf ich jetzt nicht versuchen den button einzufügen weil den button einzufügen
den will ich ja nur hier haben ok add button gibt es nicht das funktioniert soweit das
mal überlegen wie könnten wir das wie können wir das ein bisschen bisschen verbessern moment
wie ist das ich wollte noch hier den welt editor config krams einfügen settings ui wo fügt
man das überhaupt ein wo fügt man form formatting hier na komm also 80 80 zeichen ist schon
ein bisschen bisschen zu viel ist gut oder mal 120 zeichen ja ja ja das schon mal besser
ich mein 80 80 zeichen ich meine wir sind nicht mehr auf dem terminal von 1980 wir können
ruhig 80 zeichen 120 zeichen erlauben bevor er den zeilenumbruch erzwingt wie habt ihr
das bei euch eingestellt haltet ihr euch an 80 oder macht ihr auch eher 120 oder gar
noch mehr ich denke in der heutigen zeit ist es wirklich kein problem ein bisschen mehr
zu machen 80 ist vielleicht gerade was html angeht so was ein bisschen zu krass also zu
wenig ok das mal kurz in mich gehen wie können wir das mit dem button machen so add button
so was passiert denn was passiert denn bei add button add button is function add button
bla bla bla hier ist das html vom button ok dann machen wir dann machen wir das doch
jetzt mal svelte svelte like ansatzmäßig wir machen eine neue component und zwar keine
ahnung nennen wir mal add button also nicht button also ist ein extra nur dafür da punkt
svelte da kopiere ich mal das html rein das kannst du jetzt schon umbrechen das kannst
du nicht das hätte ich jetzt aber doch lieber umgebrochen wobei ne hätte ich hätte ich
nicht das will ich nicht umgebrochen haben oder doch na gut vielleicht leute ich lasse
es doch auf 80 wisst ihr warum weil ich aktuell alles auf einen bildschirm bekommen muss
normalerweise würde ich wahrscheinlich mehr machen aber ich muss ja ich muss hier zwei
sachen auf den bildschirm bekommen so button reicht das schon wie füge ich den jetzt ein
ne das reicht nicht da muss noch moment moment moment ich muss es jetzt hier als weltkomponente
nachbauen bevor ich das einfügen kann da muss noch ein diff drum herum und das das diff muss
eine id bekommen also will ich im endeffekt sowas haben diff moment wie ging das surround
surround ne surround diff ach ich bin zu dumm dafür keine ahnung wie das funktioniert
ja immer wir können einfach so machen aber klas muss toolbar sein irgendwas mit toolbar
toolbar button und das ding kriegt dann auch noch eine id dass es nicht kaputt geht von
custom dpsk button das können wir gleich alles ein bisschen schöner machen aber ich will
erst mal schauen wie man das da überhaupt rein bekommt so toolbar machen wir das hier
mal zu das brauchen wir nicht mehr so toolbar das also das was wir hier als selektor haben
ist das da oben wie füge ich das denn jetzt da ein ja das kann man das kann man schon
alles so lassen wie füge ich wie ok das weiß ich nicht wie füge ich mit welt eine komponente
ein an einer speziellen stelle von der seite wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich so wie in main
also target was der frazier ist online wirklich war wieder oder was wirklich moment das ist
doch ai frisi heißt er doch oder ist das oder ist das g bait was ist denn youtube eider
friseur was der warum hatten der sein warum hatte er noch einen channel ok ich blick
bei ihm nicht alter web games nee was spielt er denn diablo 3 der frazier ist am start
alter aber ohne ohne mikro und ohne camp oder weiß leute leute wir müssen mal kurz wir
müssen mal kurz wir müssen einmal kurz ein bisschen zusperren den spender wir müssen
lassen wir einmal wie ich mache kein rate oder so wie wir wir programmieren jetzt weiter
lassen wir mal kurz nee nee nee nee ich mache kein rate lassen wir mal kurz ein bisschen
ein bisschen zusperren moment ich bin selbst so durft das fenster aufzumachen gerade ja
ja
hat er hat er ja kein mikro dran oder kann das sein dass ich mit dem habe ich früher
videos gemacht auf youtube also falls sie jemand nicht kennt ja das mit dem habe ich
quasi angefangen auf youtube damals ok der frazier kriegt nix mit machen wir weiter machen
wir weiter ok habt ihr privat noch wir schreiben ab und zu noch ein bisschen in discord ja aber
wir kannten uns ja auch vor youtube schon ok also wo sind wir stehen geblieben popup ja
popup einfügen so button button genau button einfügen und zwar an dieser stelle ok da
muss ich muss ich google bemühen svelte insert component dom adding a svelte component to
dom at runtime exakt der kollege mit dem du bei media macht nee was you can eiser build
ist es isa oder ist es eiser oder wie spricht man das aus englisch skills eiser ich habe
gar kein sound hier drin ok was muss man machen new button what target custom api
core ok also wenn ich das richtig wenn ich das richtig verstehe kann ich jetzt sagen
new add button dann macht er den import automatisch und dann was target nee sondern ah options
klammer klammer auf target warum ist meine musik aus ok target und jetzt toolbar da is
easy ok das ist das ist das ist moment moment mein ganz so ganz so einfach ist es dann doch
nicht ich will den ich will den button ja vorne haben normalerweise hätte ich jetzt
gemacht cool bar prepend geht das vielleicht ich denke ich denke nicht dass das funktioniert
nee nee nee das geht wie kriege ich den button da jetzt vorne hin targets to render this
option ist encore a child of target to render the component immediately before also gebe ich
dann das hier an und sagt encore oder watt probieren wir das mal toolbar group ok probieren
wir das mal let anchor gleich toolbar das müssen wir so machen weil das könnte null
sein query selektor und dann was cool bar group gibt das ergibt das sinn das immer mal
so toolbar group und jetzt sagen wir hier spannend ob das funktioniert anchor das hat
so schon mal nicht funktioniert war reloaden vielleicht gleich klappt es dann klappt es
dann besser ach jetzt ist es vorne easy ok das war jetzt wirklich einfach muss man muss
man doch erstmal drauf kommen können wir das noch ein bisschen vereinfachen ich mein
toolbar button button brauchen wir doch dann gar nicht mehr sondern wir können gucken
ob es den enker gibt nee dann baue ich der endlosschleife wieder das will ich nicht hat
dieses ding vielleicht inne id oder so auto generate dpsk button könnten wir nicht sowas
machen enker query selektor und dann gucken ob er das findet auf moment moment moment
ich kacke ich habe die ich habe die klasse auch hier drauf ok noch haben wir es nicht
kaputt gemacht noch ist es noch ist alles was machst du bitte konst callback mutatist
und childless was was wie wo das da nee das da was das ist oder was meinste schwarz was
was meinste was das ist dieses konstrukt hier das ist eine api die es hier in jedem halbwegs
modern browser gibt damit kannst du gucken ob bestimmte elemente geladen werden und wenn
bestimmte elemente geladen werden dann kannst du darauf reagieren zum beispiel ich will
hier ein button einfügen so den button will ich einfügen und den button will ich nicht
irgendwo einfügen sondern exakt dort das heißt ich kucke ob das hier geladen wird und
wenn das geladen wird dann füge ich an der stelle ein wenn man wenn man selbst die komplette
webseite erstellt dann braucht man das wahrscheinlich sehr selten aber nachdem ich eine bestehende
webseite modifizieren custom sachen injecte wie das funktioniert jetzt einfach was ich
mir überlegt habe wirklich warum warum geht das ich hätte eigentlich gedacht ich fabriziere
gegen eine endlos schleife aber gut ich meine ich will mich jetzt nicht beschweren
dass es funktioniert oder so diff button toolbar nee nafbar left hätten wir noch zu bieten
aber mal so nafbar left dann ist es vielleicht so kurz das ist alles auf eine zeile oh poggers
passt alles auf eine zeile ok so ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal so weil das ist ja nicht
gar nicht die hauptsache die wir machen wollen
nee nee nee ist es nicht ist es nicht das ist nicht lokal das interface liegt das ist
in der firmware von meinem access point der access point liefert das aus und wenn du das
editieren willst müsstest du die firmware mod du musstest quasi die firmware extrahieren
dann gucken wie du die wir haben die firmware sogar hier letztens im stream schon mal extrahiert
wie du die dateien dort entpacken kannst und das ganze am ende wieder zusammenpacken in
eine funktionierende firmware und dann flaschen auf den access point das erscheint mir etwas
zu gewagt zumal beim nächsten firmware update wäre es wieder weg mit so einem userscript
ist mir das ist mir das deutlich lieber ehrlich gesagt ein weiterer grund warum ich das mache
ist einfach weil mich das thema interessiert und man wieder ein bisschen frontend zeug lernt
das welt schon fertig nee wir haben gerade erst richtig angefangen ich bin gerade dabei
diesen temple zu übersetzen von von alt zu neu ok wir haben den wir haben den button jetzt
übers welt eingefügt also welt ist jetzt ein custom custom component an der stelle ok ich
ich versuche mich mal wieder an mein welt zeug zu erinnern ich habe schon einiges ins welt
gemacht aber es ist jetzt schon bestimmt locker ein halbes jahr her wo ich zuletzt was gemacht
habe locker wenn ich sogar länger man vergisst die sachen halt relativ schnell man kommt
dann dafür aber relativ schnell rein ok wir brauchen einen store und wisst ihr wofür
wir einen store brauchen wir brauchen einen store weil hier habe ich einen button wenn
ich auf den button klicke möchte ich dieses popup anzeigen ich könnte jetzt entweder
events werfen in diesem button oder aber ich mache einfach einen store mit state drinne
für die gesamte seite was mir deutlich sinnvoller erscheint an der stelle ok swell stores wie
ging das noch mal newfile stores.js mehr weiß ich nicht mehr ich habe keine ahnung mehr
ich glaube ich glaube right store right writable store ok das klingt gut new nee nee einfach
einfach so ok let app state nee const const export const ich weiß nicht mal wie es funktioniert
hat zwelt store store file wie ging das export hey also es ist es ist fast richtig gewesen
also es ist richtig außer dass ich hinten etwas drangeschrieben habe ok so dann brauchen
wir irgendeinen state also was brauchen was brauchen wir für ich nenne es mal globale
variablen in unserer in unserer anwälte brauche ich die show dialog das ist starrmäßig falls
wir brauchen eine liste mit wlans das ist standardmäßig leeres true 0w ist standardmäßig
leer ich glaube das war es an state auch schon fast was wir brauchen mehr dürfte es eigentlich
gar nicht sein oder so und jetzt musste man den krempel irgendwie hier importieren import
app state gucke mal da ich finde es cool wieder den ganzen krempel auch erkennt ok import
so zwelt stores ok monka es ich weiß nicht mehr wie der shit funktioniert ok import
app state subscribe irgendwie so ok ja ja ok log das heißt wenn ich jetzt auf diesen
button klicke ok language es muss ich an der stelle dann machen so store nee wie habe
ich das wie habe ich app state ist das ding so ok das heißt wenn ich da drauf klicke
was jetzt geht auch alles muss man sich verstehen so wenn ich auf den button drauf klicke dann
setze möchte ich das hopup anzeigen das heißt wir gehen jetzt anders click event und machen
sowas hier click event ab was das ab ist das neu ist das ein bucking visual studio code
normalerweise kann man da noch enter drücken oder und dass das completed oder es ist ein
config setting dass das nicht so ist wieso dollar ich kann dir die hint ich kann dir
erklären warum aber ich kann dir die hintergründe nicht ganz genau erklären dollar ist die ist
eine speziale syntax für stores und normalerweise wenn ich abstate machen würde dann greifst
du auf den store zu wenn du dollar machst dann greifst du quasi auf den inhalt des
stores zu haben wir das verstanden die hintergründe kann ich dir leider nicht genau erklären
wie es das wie es das macht ok so wenn ich jetzt den eine minute warum ist der button
nicht da der war doch eben noch da was ist jetzt los ich habe es kaputt gemacht war das
nicht anders rum was dann um ist was ist jetzt ich habe es ich habe es gebraked warum was
habe ich was hat wo was wo habe ich es kaputt gemacht an welcher stelle habe ich es zerstört
hier vielleicht wo habe ich es jetzt kaputt gemacht vielleicht hier mal gucken wir fühlen
es aber noch mal aus jetzt geht es wieder was hat er format error was wo der import stimmt
nicht der import stimmt nicht stores js doch so eigentlich so eigentlich richtig
ok was habe ich denn jetzt kaputt gemacht mensch was ist denn das problem ist ach moment
ich weiß wo das problem ist ah easy ok ich weiß wo das problem ist das problem ist hier
in buttons dass der import nicht stimmt es müsste so sein wahrscheinlich stores was
habe ich denn verkehrt gemacht ich habe es wieder aus ok es geht wieder es geht wieder
es geht wieder ich habe es wieder gefixt ich habe irgendwie ich habe falschen fad eingetragen
button ist auch wieder da ok das funktioniert wenn ich auf den button drücke dann sagt
er schon dialog gleich true also das heißt wir machen jetzt noch mal ein eine weiteres
welt component dialog punkt welt und dort kopieren wir diesen ganzen schmatter rein von hier bis
hier hier können wir eigentlich main auch entfernen und styles können wir auch entfernen
wir brauchen hier plus script tags oder geht alles dialog hin zu nein nein nein nein nein
spaces zwei dachte das hast du gelernt so schau dialog gibt es nicht also script language
gleich ts let gleich true so das heißt wenn wir jetzt auf den button drücken brauche
ich nicht ich kann einfach den store nehmen ich bin ja auch doof app store bin bescheuert
was macht ihr denn hier mit source stores ist doch eigentlich komplett komplett broken
oder app states show ok so jetzt sollte das funktionieren wenn ich den wenn ich den button
drück wenn ich den button drücke dann sollte eigentlich jetzt ein pop-up
ah moment moment ich bin ja auch blöd ich renne das ding ja nirgendwo ich renne das
teile nirgendwo das muss ja irgendwo irgendwo hin muss es ja ja irgendwo irgendwo hin muss
es ja da ist es doch geht doch ok noch mal ausprobieren irgendwo hin muss ich habe sie
gar nicht gemeldet ok dynamic psk ok jetzt funktioniert es nice so das heißt wir können
jetzt auch schon mal gleich hier an den schließen button gehen und die ganzen ids löschen die
hier drin sind brauchen wir nämlich alle nicht mehr brauchen die ganzen ids nicht mehr
können wir uns komplett komplett schenken so und jetzt cancel sagt click on click sagen
wir jetzt einfach app states das nervt mich ja dass man das nicht enter drücken kann
schon gleich falls cancel nice aha ich kann ich kann ein pop-up auf und zu machen easy
was x was für den x ach so ja stimmt zum x so du hast recht das x braucht das natürlich
auch noch genau weil wir können ja hier oben drauf klicken zum schließen das habe ich
ganz vergessen hier klick nice was ist hier für ein problem
jetzt muss ich jetzt ein gift rum machen dass er nicht dass er nicht meckert oder wie wenn
ich mache da ich mache da auch ein gift rum gift rum wenn es sein muss alter was will natürlich
kann man in i anklicken man kann alles anklicken das ist schon mal egal es hat sogar ein hover
effekt guck mal es hat sogar ein hover effekt mein das ist das ist disable was will er was
will er mir eigentlich sagen a 11 y visible non interactive elements with on click event
must be accompanied by on key down
ach das ist für barrierefreiheit oder was ok das juckt mich bei meinem user script für
meinen access point absolut gar nicht jetzt nerven nicht rum mit komischen gelben kringeln
ok nice jetzt passt das kann ich hier klicken kann ich da klicken und das ganze geht auf
und zu nice so weiter im text so wir müssen jetzt gucken wie wir die wlan informationen
her bekommen die wlan informationen bekommen wir das ist ein bisschen kompliziert das kann
ich übrigens zumachen das werde ich nie wieder brauchen es ist ein bisschen kompliziert
und zwar wlan infos gibt es von default store also die web anwendung hier ist eigentlich
eine react anwendung das heißt ich muss jetzt gucken wie kriege ich aus dem react store
die wlan infos raus ok ich habe eine idee leute ich habe eine idee wie wir das machen können
ich habe in meinem in meinem store was für wlan das heißt wir filtern uns das einfach
raus an der stelle jetzt ein bisschen ein bisschen irritiert wie wir das machen am besten
aus dort was weg weg ne ne das kann nicht funktionieren ok ok wie könnte man wie könnte
man das gescheit machen das welt ist richtig poggers war eine blöde sache hat der react
store auch so was wie subscrib window default store was hatten das ding dispatch get states
replace reducer alles klar subscrib aha aha aha aha ok wie heißt seine dark mode erweiterung
für firefox dark reader react store jetzt jetzt muss ich mal in mich gehen wie könnte
man das hier gescheit machen also subscrib subscrib gut das kann er nicht auto komplizieren
weil er überhaupt nicht weiß was das ist das leuchtet mir ein subscrib ich hoffe mal
das funktioniert so auch mal da überhaupt was oder so leute nach was soll ich in suchen
react react store subscrib store subscrib alles klar wie verwendet man das ich habe keine
ahnung ich habe absolut kein plan von fun react subscrib ads a changeless dann will
die karte called anytime das example check ich nicht wie benutzt man das
ok wenn sich das state ändert dann also brauchen wir irgendein event wahrscheinlich so log und
die feind ok das geht schon gut los nice sehr schön und die feinde geht das so schon mal
nett benutzt man den kram denn gescheit wo kommt denn hier store überhaupt her gibt
es irgendwelche magic variablen oder so oder einfach hier einfach so jetzt state ok da
habe ich nichts gesagt das ist dann wirklich das dann wirklich einfach ok also get store
wlan svc list data das dürfte jetzt ja null sein erstmal standardmäßig empty array und
sobald ich wlan daten lade steht da was drin ok das ist doch schon mal gut also dann machen
wir das so if get state das hier mal let oder const data gleich so wenn data length größer
null dann setze ich mein app state wlan auf data nee nee ich will das ja noch ein bisschen
umformatieren dann setze ich das hier auf wlan auf neue geklammere mist fuck wo fehlt
die klammer ich habe ja was gibt immer richtige probleme hier da die die da hier so oder wie
ja ok also wenn ich das jetzt richtig gemacht habe dann sollte ich app state ey warum kann
ich da nicht enter drücken was ist denn das für ein kack das ist doch nicht schon immer
so ein wischlös guck mal deselekt der selected das gar nicht mehr automatisch zum enter drücken
wie es code enter intellisense complete devils arch danke für den sub das ist doch nicht
schon immer so gewesen ja tap aber nee nee das das das ging du konntest auch früher
immer enter drücken an der stelle jetzt wobei konntest du konntest du oder ja ja konntest
du auf jeden fall ist das ein bug na max normal ist das nicht so normal kannst du normal normal
das kannst du hier an enter drücken denn der selekte das nicht mehr es rief moin heute
heute wird svelte action gemacht das erste ist nicht except suggestions on enter probieren
mal aus settings except und enter is on ja das ist aber nicht preselected die die geschichte
das ist ein bug glaube ich jetzt ist natürlich die frage ist es ein bug in der svelte component
oder in probieren wir noch mal hier aus das ist ein bug in der svelte component oder ja
komm mal das ist ein bug in der svelte component hier geht's in diesem svelte tool hier geht's
jetzt bin ich jetzt bin ich komplett komplett verwirrt
jetzt geht's wo ging es denn eben nicht
okay keine ahnung anscheinend anscheinend ist jetzt wieder alles gut aus irgendwelchen
irgendwelchen gründen ist es kaputt so jetzt bin ich natürlich ein bisschen ein bisschen
rausgekommen doch funktioniert das hier mit den wlans laden jetzt ja wlans testwlan ok
nice nice funktioniert funktioniert alles habe ich die wlans hier drinne gut mehr brauchen
wir hier an der stelle nicht das heißt wir wir schaufeln den kram jetzt vom react store
in den swell store sehr schön nice und das kann weg das heißt wir können den knopf
drücken das heißt es fehlt doch jetzt eigentlich nur noch die sache wo wirklich das password
angelegt wird der rest klappt doch jetzt schon also muss jetzt hier bei dialog rein also
eigentlich eigentlich fehlt doch nur noch also dass ihr mit den wlans funktioniert wobei
funktioniert das mit den wlans hier drinne auch dialog wisst ihr wisst ihr was praktisch
ist jetzt kann ich endlich gescheites gescheites template hier verwenden für anstatt den kram
hier zu machen select vorher vorher musste ich so ekliche sachen hier machen das brauche
ich jetzt gar nicht mehr jetzt kann ich options options each each wlan ne warte appstate ey
was ist das das nerv was redux ins welt ich kann dir sagen warum ganz einfach dieses web
interface von einem access point ist in react programmiert und hatten zwelt und hatten in
redux store und ich versuche das gerade und ich habe keine ahnung von react und die anwendung
ist ja quasi auch schon fertig gebaut ich versuche die gerade ein bisschen zu erweitern
und das mache ich mit zwelt das heißt ich muss jetzt manche daten vom react store überschaffen
in den zwelt store aber warum geht denn dieses auto komplett nicht es liegt vielleicht an
dem dollar app ok das muss irgendwas hier mit zu tun haben irgendwas muss hier irgendwas
muss hier kaputt sein appstate
balance wiele
suggest selection first
Guck mal
Was suggest select selection first ja
Es scheint ein bug in das in das Weltding zu sein
So wenn ich jetzt das hier aufmache dann habe ich jetzt WLANs drinne stehen. Oh fast fast richtig
Test WLAN. Ups ne
Ah das Dollar kann auch weg
Passt sehr sehr sehr sehr nice nice
So warum die Autokomplete hier aussteigt weiß ich nicht da ist irgendwas kaputt das ist irgendein Bug in diesem in diesem Svelte Teil
Ich habe mir die WLANs gestattet. So was kommt was kommt jetzt als nächstes jetzt muss ich ja dafür sorgen
Das das anlegen des users das ist eigentlich das einzige was noch fehlt das anlegen des users fehlt also quasi
Das da im Endeffekt
So
Das kommt jetzt natürlich nicht an die stelle sondern wir brauchen so was hier Funktion
Create und klick wenn man jetzt noch tippen könnte klick
Save oder etwas create
create
Gibt es eine möglichkeit das jetzt hier anzulegen um add missing
function
Was
Das ist ja auch verkehrt
Kann ich das kann ich das jetzt anlegen lassen weil so will ich das bestimmt nicht haben
Add missing function any ja Typescript nervt mich
Ok und da kommt jetzt der ganze schritt rein der natürlich nicht funktioniert weil es async sein muss
Und wir brauchen ganz viel zeug davon nicht ich komme ich kommentiere das mal aus und eine Reihe nach wieder ein
so also
user
selektor das brauchen wir nicht das kann hier
Variabler werden hier user let user let password
So jetzt muss ich das bein an die inputs für user also value value gleich
gleich
User
dann probieren wir gleich mal aus ob das funktioniert ich habe da meine zweifel dass meine svelte
skills im hinter und value ist hier doppelt dass meine svelte skills so
Frisch noch sind dass ich das auf die reihe kriege hier password
Was ist das nicht bing value was
Muss es nicht also doch muss es muss es moment
doch du hast recht muss es ich habe doch gesagt meine svelte skills ich war so wirklich auf
frisch im kopf du hast recht es muss bein sein sonst funktioniert das mit data bindings reinschreiben nicht mehr
Ja das richtig das richtig
Okay, dann loggen wir das mal und schauen ob das funktioniert
Also was ist jetzt was habe ich jetzt schon wieder kaputt gemacht mann was ist denn jetzt
Alter ich habe doch überhaupt nichts geändert hier an der stelle
Vor allem die javascript-fehlermeldung wieder
Oh Gott, oh Gott, bitte nicht diese dummen fehlermeldungen die keiner checkt mann
Das sind noch das ist richtig aber
Okay, es hat ein problem bei dialog und warum
Wo ist das problem im port sind richtig ja
create wo ist wo ist jetzt das problem mann
Ich habe doch gar nichts geändert an der stelle ist auch ist auch alles legit wie vorher
Okay leute da hilft nur eins
Naja vielleicht ist hier auch das problem
Ach guck mal habe ich gar nicht gesehen value ist doppelt
Ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen dass da was rot ist
Jetzt geht es wahrscheinlich auch wieder
electrical critical information korrekt services
blablabla blablabla create
Achso ich habe das event rausgelöscht
Alter wie mich das nervt dass man nicht enter drücken kann
Es kann ich ja übrigens zeigen wie easy das hier mit12 umzusetzen ist dass
Da die passwortlänge aktualisiert guckt mal hier wir haben hier unten
Wenn wir unten die Länge drin stehen von dem Passwort, da kann ich jetzt einfach reinschreiben.
Passwort, Length, Klammern drum herum und jetzt MAGIC, MAGIC.
Ah, ich weiß warum, ich bin, weil es nicht initialisiert ist.
Jetzt funktioniert, was zum, sag mal, warum geht das Laufen kaputt?
Alter, was will der das von mir?
Hä, es ist exakt wie vorher und jetzt gibt es keinen Fehler mehr?
Manchmal verstehe ich das, ja, was gibt es euch wirklich nicht?
Achtung, guck mal, jetzt update das auch, seht ihr das?
Ich schreibe jetzt hier Passwörter rein und update direkt die Länge hinten dran.
Boah, das habe ich jetzt nicht kapiert, warum es jetzt auf einmal kaputt war und das gleiche,
ich habe ja einfach nur Ctrl-Z gedrückt, rückgängig gemacht, jetzt geht.
Ich schiebe es auch auf JavaScript, ja, also Brainlag, wenn du was wissen willst, was wir
genau machen, kannst du fragen, du bist, glaube ich, das erste Mal im Stream oder zumindest
seit einer Weile, ne, du bist nicht das erste Mal, du hast schon acht Messages geschrieben,
gleich mal gestalked hier, ähm, wir modifizieren das Webinterface von meinem Accesspoint.
Okay, also, okay, User haben wir, Validation ist, ja, wie machen wir die, ich kopiere das
jetzt einfach mal, ich will jetzt erstmal gucken, dass es funktioniert.
Validation, Validate Input, das können wir natürlich viel schöner ins Welt jetzt machen
als wie wir das in JavaScript gemacht haben, aber so, let validation result, wir müssen
auf jeden Fall schon mal nichts mehr übergeben, weil User und Passwort können wir so drauf
zugreifen, das können wir mehr oder weniger so lassen, if validation result, ah, wir brauchen
was für Error, let error, error ist nix, standardmäßig, error, gleich, validation result, return, wo
ist der error, da, error, okay, wenn jetzt es funktioniert und ich klicke auf create
soll eine Fehlermeldung oben kommen, hey, User and Passwort cannot be empty, Passwort
must be greater than 24, wenn ich ein Komma in User hab, Komma nicht erlaubt, nice, okay,
sehr schön, ach, oh, ich glaub ich hab schon direkt n Bug gefunden, guck mal, wenn ich
canceln mach und mach wieder auf, dann resettert sich das nicht, das ist doof, da muss ich
mir gleich noch was überlegen zu, ich könnte, ach nee, Moment, das ist eigentlich glaub
relativ einfach, wir gucken einfach, wenn sich das ändert, if AppState, Alter, AppState
show dialog, dann resetten wir einfach Error, sobald der Dialog neu aufgemacht wird, resetten
wir einfach den Error, so hier, create, Error, bam, neu aufgemacht, Error weg, sehr schön,
das kann man wahrscheinlich eleganter machen, aber mir fällt grad nix anderes ein, wir
machen jetzt, wir sorgen jetzt erstmal dafür, dass es funktioniert, so, CSV, Formdata, Formdata,
das brauchen wir alles nach wie vor, da hat sich nix geändert, nee, Dollar Doppelpunkt
ist SvelteMagic, alles was hier drinnen steht, also jede Variable, die du hier verwendest,
wird unter der Haube gecaptured und sobald die sich ändert, wird diese Funktion nochmal
neu ausgeführt, also dadurch, dass ich hier zugreife auf den AppState, sobald sich Show
sich ändert, wird das wieder ausgeführt, jedesmal, das ist quasi Reactivity fürs Welt,
ok, also soweit funktioniert das schonmal, da dürfte ja nix großartig kaputt sein jetzt,
war ja vorher auch schon so, so, Selected WLAN-ID, das brauchen wir noch, Let Selected WLAN-ID
ist Null, weil wir das Welt haben, können wir das jetzt ein bisschen einfacher machen,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher an was ich binden kann, Value wahrscheinlich, Value, Selected
WLAN-ID, also wenn ich jetzt hier was auswähle, in dem WLAN-Tropdown, dann steht das Ergebnis
mit der ID in Selected WLAN-ID, es wäre natürlich cooler, wenn ich irgendwie direkt WLAN hier
rein bekomme, aber ich glaube das funktioniert so nicht, ich bekomme ja nur den Value, so,
das heißt ich brauche jetzt wieder sowas hier, das brauchen wir nicht, ich brauche wieder
Selected WLAN, AppState, WLANsFind, WLAN mit dieser WLAN-ID, ok, das muss ich jetzt mal
locken ob das soweit alles funktioniert, klingt ja alles schön und gut, aber ob das
wirklich so ist, lass uns mal ausspringen Create, easy, funktioniert, geht alles, weis,
so dann haben wir hier das XML, frag bitte nichts, warum das XML ist Leute, die sind
der Meinung, dass es eine gute Idee ist eine API zu haben, in der du verschachteltes XML
benutzen musst, um dem Access Point zu sagen, was er machen soll, also die API ist so ziemlich
eines der hässlichsten Sachen, die ich je gesehen habe, aber das muss man so machen,
sonst funktioniert es nicht, so nice, extremely nice, so Selected WLAN Name, Selected WLAN
ID, das stimmt immer noch und jetzt können wir eigentlich uploaden, das wars, ja ja das
gibt es auch, ok, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wir haben noch vergessen, dass er die Seite
refreshen soll, das müssen wir hier noch einbauen, Seite refreshen und dann wollen
wir eigentlich noch AppState, ShowDialogFaults, so, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla, create, easy, es geht einfach, einfach
user angelegt, das ist heute der letzte JavaScript Access Point Modding Stream, danach gehts vermute
ich mal, easy as fuck, nice, ok wir haben die Funktionalität wieder hergestellt, wie
es das letzte Mal war, wir können User adden und wir können User wieder löschen, ok sehr
schön, sonderlich hübsch ist es jetzt vielleicht noch nicht, aber ich denke damit kann man
leben, ich meine eigentlich siehts gar nicht so schlimm aus oder, doch durchaus alles
ganz gut lesbar, blickt man doch durch was da passiert, ich denke mal schon, das ist ok,
ich glaube ich muss mal kurz gucken, die Katze ist an der Tür, Sekunde ich bin gleich
am Start, Wupp Pet, geht jetzt auf den Schrank und legt sich ab, war Neo Wim Config, das
können wir wahrscheinlich an einem der nächsten Streams angehen, oder wie würde man im Business
Deutsch jetzt sagen, da sind wir dran, wir arbeiten mit Hochdruck an der Erstellung eines
Streams, das passt soweit, was passiert hier, ich füge Sachen in das Web Interface von
meinem Access Point hinzu, die es standardmäßig nicht hat, guck dieser Button hier und dieses
Popup und diese Geschichte hier um User hinzuzufügen zu können, gibt es normalerweise im Access
Point gar nicht, du kannst normalerweise nur Batch generieren, mehrere User mit keinem
extra Passwort, willst du die komplett from scratch, klar natürlich, ich hatte selbst
schon mal Wim Configs, die waren keine Ahnung 800 oder noch länger, noch mehr als 800 Zeilen
lang, das kriege ich schon hin, ich habe nicht vor Neo Wim krass gemoddet zu benutzen, aber
mich interessiert einfach mal was sich da getan hat, ich glaube das können wir so lassen
wie es ist, vielleicht können wir diese Sache hier noch ein bisschen aufsplitten, ein bisschen
schöner machen, aber warum sollte man alles aufsplitten, was logisch irgendwo zusammen
gehört, ne ne das mache ich selbst, ich will da was beilernen, kannst du auf meine Frage
eingehen, was hast du denn geschrieben, habe ich nicht gesehen, Leute wenn ich irgendwas
über sehe, dann müsst ihr ein Wubblos davor schreiben, sonst wird das bei mir manchmal
nicht angezeigt, beziehungsweise doch wird angezeigt, aber ich sehe es nicht, so zeig
mal her, du hast überhaupt nichts gefragt, oder, ach doch da oben, ist der Build Modus
Spiel wichtig oder kann ich meine Bevorzug der Einstellung ohne erhebliche Einbesch...
Ich erkenne den Zusammenhang nicht und weiß nicht was du wissen willst, ist der Build Modus
Spiel wichtig oder kann ich meine Bevorzug der Einstellung ohne erhebliche Einstellung
ohne erhebliche Einstellung oder kann ich meine Bevorzug der Einstellung ohne erhebliche
Einstellung ohne erhebliche Einstellung nicht, ja, ich glaube ich weiß, was du wissen willst,
du meinst ob in einem Spiel es wichtig ist, ob man Fullscreen, oder Window Fullscreen
oder sowas auswählt oder ja ja das dachte ich mir auch gerade, es hat ein bisschen gedauert,
dem Stream zu tun, aber cool Cupman, ähm, theoretisch, theoretisch hast du mit Fullscreen,
also richtig echtem Fullscreen, aber nur theoretisch, hast du theoretisch ein bisschen weniger Input
lag und eventuell ein bisschen mehr Performance, weil der Windows, ähm, wie heißt das, der
DWM nicht mehr dazwischen ist, also nicht mehr, nicht mehr der Windows Renderer für
Fenster, für Composite Renderer für Windows dazwischen ist, also der theoretisch ein bisschen
besser, wenn du richtig Fullscreen hast, aber praktisch gesehen macht es eigentlich nicht
so viel Unterschied, also du kannst das machen, wenn du irgendwie Probleme hast, aber ich
würde nicht darauf hoffen, dass du ein Spiel hast, was schlecht läuft, das in Fullscreen
machst, dass es dann besser läuft, wirklich, ähm, ich rede von meinem Fernseher, ok, dann
habe ich legit keine Ahnung, was du meinst, kommt das direkt aus Chat-GPT oder, das, das
könnte man tatsächlich machen, da gibt es dann demnächst, wer, wer richtig liegt, irgendwie
fünfmal hintereinander, der kriegt nens abgegiftet, ach du meinst, ob du das Spiele-Preset, ob
das Spiele-Preset vom Fernseher sich lohnt, ja, manche Fernseher haben Spiele-Presets,
das ist richtig, ob sich das bei deinem Fernseher lohnt, kann man pauschal nicht sagen, das
hängt vom Fernseher ab, und, ähm, je nachdem, was der macht, da musst du irgendeinen Test
zum Fernseher angucken, das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen, ansonsten probier es halt einfach
aus, ob es für dich nennenswerten Unterschied ist, also, es gibt Fernseher, da macht es
einen enormen Unterschied, da kannst du quasi im Spielmodus Fast-Input-Lag frei spielen
und im normalen Modus halt nicht, weil der zig Bildoptimierungsgeschichten macht, bei
anderen Fernsehern ist das nicht so, das musst du, musst du den Test zum Fernseher angucken
oder ausprobieren, das kann man pauschal nicht sagen, aber es wird wahrscheinlich auch keinen
Unterschied, also, es wird auch nicht schaden, wenn du das einschaltest, so, gut, nachdem
wir jetzt die Funktionalität vom letzten Mal wieder hergestellt haben, ich muss mal
kurz nebenbei ein bisschen in Discord gucken, ob wir heute Abend MMO-Kreisel-Cry machen,
das war mehr random als die Senf-Frage, stimmt, wo ist der, wo ist der Senf-Liebhaber eigentlich
heute, wie geht es dir heute, ich hatte Urlaub, was heißt Urlaub, ich habe Montags immer frei,
dementsprechend geht es mir frei, frei gut, so, also, die Funktionalität haben wir jetzt
ja so eingebaut, wie es letztes Mal war, wir können User generieren, wir können Passwörter
generieren, wenn das Ganze zu kurz ist, gibt es Fehler und so, alles gut, jetzt können
wir das Ganze ein bisschen erweitern, als letztes Mal, ähm, hatte doch jemand vorgeschlagen
oder habe ich es vielleicht sogar selbst vorgeschlagen, nicht mehr so sicher, dass wir noch ein Button
machen könnten zum random Passwort generieren, oder wir hatten, Moment, wir hatten doch
schon ein random, wir haben doch schon ein random Passwort generiert hier, Generate Password,
haben wir doch schon, ich habe mal eine Frage an euch, ihr habt doch ein bisschen mehr Plan,
was Frontend-Sachen angeht, zumindest, zumindest einige, ich habe, ich habe, ich habe zwei,
warum machst du nicht standardmäßig ein random Passwort rein, das ist eine gute Idee, hatten
wir das letzte Mal auch schon, das machen wir auch, ich habe mal eine Frage an euch,
ähm, also zwei, eine, eine, wo ich gar keine Ahnung davon habe, ich habe mich heute mal
ein bisschen mit React beschäftigt, weil das einer der Frontend-Frameworks ist, wo ich noch
nie was großartig mitgemacht habe, und, ne, da ist nicht kopiert der Code, der einzige
Code, den ich kopiert habe, ist der hier, der Rest ist, den haben wir hier alles gerade
live erstellt und vom letzten Mal rüber kopiert, das haben wir selbst gebaut, nur das hier
nicht, also mit dem, ähm, mit dem Passwort-Kram, ja, also, was ich euch fragen wollte, ist folgendes,
ich habe heute ein Tutorial gelesen zu React, ich habe nicht vor, großartig was mit React
zu machen, aber mir ist eine Sache aufgefallen, und zwar, äh, JSX-Example-Class-Name, so,
mir ist nämlich aufgefallen, dass man, ich habe natürlich kein Beispiel, also mir ist
nämlich aufgefallen, dass man in, äh, React, in React schreibt man ja quasi HTML in JavaScript,
und nicht wie umgedreht normalerweise JavaScript in HTML, so, und, die verwenden anstatt Class,
jaja, das ist mir klar, Chat, wartet doch mal ab, bevor ihr was beantwortet, wo ihr noch
gar nicht wissen wollt, was ich wissen will, ihr könnt doch auch gar nicht wissen, was
ich fragen will, so, ich weiß warum das so ist, Chat ist wieder überaktiv gerade, also,
die mussten hier ja Class-Name verwenden, weil Class in JavaScript schon vorhanden ist,
soweit so gut, heißt im Endeffekt, man kann HTML-Sachen nicht mal gescheit copy-pasten
und so, alles gut, aber, was ich, was ich mich sofort dabei gefragt habe, ist, wenn
jetzt JavaScript ein neues Keyword einfügt, dann bricht das potentiell jegliches JSX,
nämlich wenn der Kram bisher normal verwendet werden konnte, also wenn du irgendwas hast,
was du in JSX normal verwenden kannst oder verwendest, und JavaScript führt das als Keyword
ein, ist Instant alles an JSX kaputt, das heißt doch im Endeffekt, die Leute, die JavaScript
erweitern, die müssen sich, obwohl JSX nichts offizielles ist, in dem Sinn, das ist aber
verbreitet als Fuck, die dürfen quasi nichts in JavaScript einbauen, in Zukunft, was in
JSX verwendet wird, weil ansonsten Instant jegliche React-Anwendung kaputt ist, seh
ich doch richtig, oder?
Jaja, ich weiß, ich weiß, die werden das wahrscheinlich gar nicht machen, weil React
so verbreitet ist, aber es ist doch doof, dass jetzt quasi die JavaScript-Standardisierung
Rücksicht darauf nehmen muss, was irgendein Framework macht, weil es eben HTML und CSS
in JavaScript macht, aber gut, dann hab ich das richtig verstanden, dann wäre das so,
warum sollen sie das müssen, naja, weil sonst jede React-Anwendung kaputt ist, und ich glaube
nicht, dass es im Sinne der JavaScript-Standardisierung ist, wo ja sicherlich auch Google, Mozilla
und alle mit dabei hocken, wahrscheinlich auch Facebook, und hast du nicht gesehen,
dass React kaputt geht, das heißt, die müssen sich vielleicht nicht in der Theorie danach
richten, so nach dem Motto, ich könnte eigentlich machen, was sie wollen, aber dann würden sie
ganz viele React-Anwendungen kaputt machen, also gehen wir mal von aus, gehen wir mal von
aus, dass jetzt ClassName, wenn jetzt ClassName ein JavaScript-reserviertes Wort sein sollte,
ist instant, und ClassName ist ja nicht alles, so onClick gibt es ja auch noch, ja, onClick
und sowas, also mal angenommen, es gäbe jetzt in JavaScript eine neue Schlüsselwort, was
sich onClick nennt, dann wäre doch instant jegliche React-Anwendung kaputt, sobald man
einen Browser verwendet, der diesen JavaScript-Standard unterstützt, weil klar, da sind wahrscheinlich
2-3 Jahre Vorlauf dazwischen, aber ist schon irgendwie doof, oder, ne, aber selbst wenn
Facebook das implementiert, es ist ja bisher so, es steht ja bisher so drin, also müssten
dann alle anderen das anpassen, oder Facebook müsste irgendwie ein Convert-Tool oder so
bereitstellen, was dann aber auch schwierig wäre, wenn das Convert-Tool in einer Sprachversion
läuft, die schon das neue Schlüsselwort hat, also es ist halt ein bisschen komisch,
ja gut, so, da hätten wir das eine schon geklärt, jetzt mal meine andere Frage an die ganzen
Frontend-Experten hier, wo speichert man dann am besten solche Helper-Functions hier, Generate-Password,
ich könnte das natürlich hier drinnen anlegen, weil ich brauche es nur in diesem Dialog,
in dieser Dialog-Komponente, ja, das ist in dem Fall schon okay, aber mal angenommen,
ich würde das an mehreren Stellen verwenden wollen, gibt es da irgendwie so eine Convention,
wie man das macht, so helper.js oder irgendwie sowas, ich mein, ich könnte es theoretisch
wahrscheinlich in Store klatschen, aber da gehört es ja nicht hin, ich mache meist
eine Helper-Ordnung für jede Funktionsgruppe eine Datei, also ins Welt am besten in lib
Functions, okay, feifert, also hier hin und jetzt functions.js oder wie, oder einen Ordner
anlegen der Functions heißt, zweld, wir suchen mal, lib Functions, oder auch nicht, inside
your lib Functions-Folder, wo kommt denn das lib Functions überhaupt her, gibt es
kein Leitfaden für sowas, wir sind hier im Frontend JavaScript Umfeld, da gibt es keinen
und Millionen Leitfaden, ne, das ist nichts, also ich mein, wir können das doch theoretisch
auch einfach so in lib, wobei ne, komm, also instinktiv würde ich sowas hier machen,
so, jetzt füge ich das hier ein, okay, und wie greife ich da jetzt drauf zu, einfach
import, Helper oder wie, ne, einfach so, easy, ne so oder, so geht doch auch, jetzt kann
ich das, oder macht man das so nicht, das soll alles rein, warum ist App dann da, also
das soll wahrscheinlich alles rein, was nicht gerade App ist, aber so, aber so wird es doch
auch funktionieren, oder, kann ich dann, kann ich jetzt im Endeffekt sagen, an der Stelle
hier unten, ne, wir machen das anders, Passwort, Passwort ist Generate Password, so 48, zack,
Generate Password is not defined, aber der Auto completed das doch, ich muss einen Export
davor machen, ganz fast, ach und jetzt, okay, okay, okay, und jetzt muss ich sagen Generate
Password, so, ha, from, ah, okay, und wenn ich jetzt mal angenommen, mal angenommen,
ich hab jetzt Generate Password 1, Generate Password 2, dann müsste ich das dann so jetzt
hier machen, oder, okay, verstehe, der Vorteil vom lib-Folder ist, dass du einen dynamischen
Import hast, sprich import from, stimmt, ja, da kann ich mich dran erinnern, so macht man
das eigentlich auch, ja, hast recht, ich erinnere mich, dollar lib, ja, ja, ja, da kann ich
mich dran erinnern, und zack, haben wir, haben wir ein Passwort drin, poggers, zwar immer
das gleiche, was auch ein bisschen doof ist, also machen wir das auch hier rein, Passwort,
gleich, hop, jedes mal wenn das Ding neu aufgemacht wird, nice, ja, der Frazier ist, er hat ja
jetzt eigentlich ein Mikrofon dran, oder nicht, wir haben ja vorhin schon bei ihm reingeguckt,
I frisien, sagt er, sagt er mittlerweile was, oder ist er immer noch im Criant-Modus, alter,
meine Ohren, ja, er ist immer noch im Criant-Modus und sagt nichts.
Dann werfe ich mal eine random Frage, arbeitest du dein WSL, nee, nee, nee, kein WSL, das ist
extra für euch installiert, weil ihr das gerne seht, Leute, das ist Archlinux, was
auch sonst, by the way, Arch, das einzige, die einzige wahre, most superior Linux Distribution
auf dem ganzen Planeten, außer vielleicht Gentoo, oder noch cooler, wie die, wie die
geilen Leute Gentoo sagen, Vm war 20, wo ist das Problem, nee, das ist eine Vm, guck,
hier hab ich Windows, mit OBS und aller möglichen Zeug, Terminal und Browser und, und Gramm
und irgendwie ganz viel Kindermusik, weil YouTube der Meinung ist, ich will das unbedingt
hören, ich will LazyTown mir jetzt angucken, und hier hab ich mal eine Linux-Kiste, inner
vm, Shenku, nee, das kenn ich nicht, ich, ich, ich, ich kenn nur Gentoo, oder, oder,
oder Gentoo, ja, was manche Leute aussprechen, aber Arch beste Leute, Archlinux, by the
way, by the way, I use Arch, by the way. Wann machen wir mal Gentoo?
So, ich muss mich gerade um MMO-Kreiselgrind kümmern, für heut Abend, wir mussten, wir
mussten gerade klären, wann heut Abend MMO-Kreiselgrind startet, ok, also, was bauen wir denn jetzt
noch ein, wir haben jetzt ja im Prinzip nur die Funktionalität nachgebaut, vom, wie es
vorher gewesen ist, wir machen jetzt noch ein extra Button, wir machen jetzt noch ein extra
Button da unten hin, ein extra Button für Passwort generieren, und dann verschiedene
Passwort-Generator-Methoden, nee, wir nehmen mal den Button hier, wie sieht denn der Button
aus? Wir klauen uns den jetzt einfach, außer HTML, China-Chinesen-Klon, vom Button, bei
AliExpress bestellen, so, wo machen wir den Button denn jetzt hin? So, da ist das Popup,
das kommt hier unten drunter, also Passwort, da, bla, bla, diff, oh Gott, das ist immer
so unleserlich, das HTML-Zeug, man, wo sind wir denn hier überhaupt? Diff, Row, ok, jetzt
haben wir einen Button, das stimmt aber so noch nicht, wir müssen jetzt einen Button
machen, und da unten drunter müssen wir das diff schließen, sonst backen. Ist das diff
da oben gerade verschwunden? Ok, na dann, alles gut, das da werden wir wahrscheinlich
brauchen, nee, kacke aus, stimmt was nicht, Field, Control, was auch immer, ah nee, Moment,
ok, Sekunde Leute, wir müssen das da, wir müssen das da copy-pasten, das da copy-pasten,
dann brauchen wir den Button, und das da unten kommt wieder weg, so, der Button kommt an
die Stelle vom Input, ah Gott, HTML, please, man, so kompliziert kann das doch gar nicht
sein, wo ist das Problem? Ah, hier, weirdflex, so Passwort, Kerl, randomize heißt das Ding
jetzt, randomize, so, ok, der Knopf macht noch nichts, was ist denn das, ist das font-awesome,
was die verwenden? Die haben doch bestimmt schönere Icons für Passwort-Generieren,
nein, nein, nein, ja, hier, wo kann man hier suchen, haben die nicht irgendwo nen Suchfeld
für Icons, Icons, so, random, ok, das ist gar nicht mal so verkehrt, haben wir sowas
wie Passwort vielleicht, key, nee, random ist glaub ich besser, Secret vielleicht was,
oder HTTPS, ok, dann nehmen wir random, oh, jetzt haben wir so random-button, ok, random-button
dürfte recht easy sein, on-click, on-click, passiert eigentlich nix anderes wie Passwort,
oh, das macht mich verrückt, dass ich nicht Enter drücken kann hier, gleich, generate
Passwort, 48, easy, passwort randomize, wobei das natürlich so relativ unsinnig ist, man
müsste vielleicht noch ein bisschen Auswahl einstellbar machen, wie man das Ganze generieren
will, also, ein Slider für die Länge vielleicht und, ist das eigentlich Bootstrap, was sie
da verwenden, meint ihr das, ist das hier Bootstrap-Syntax, was, Key Skeleton Left Right, ne, gibt es
nicht, ist Bootstrap, ok, wie macht man nen Slider, Bootstrap, Slider, so nen, nee, ich
will sowas, falls es da überhaupt sowas gibt, ich will, nee, nee, nee, nicht Slider, wie
heißen das in HTML, so nen Range Input, Range, genau, ja, genau, das meine ich, Bootstrap,
wie bekommt man die Bootstrap-Version raus, habt ihr nen Plan, sieht man das hier vielleicht
irgendwo, Bootstrap, vielleicht im CSS, Bootstrap 3.41, das ist glaube ich ganz schön alt,
aber, easy as, no, god, no, god, please no, das ist 4 Jahre alt, das ist 4 Jahre alt,
na gut, Bootstrap Trial 3 Hilfe, gibt es doch bestimmt immer noch, oder, ja, ja, ok, 3
Punkt, was war es, 3.41, ok, sehr gut, sehr gut, ich glaube mehr geht da wahrscheinlich
nicht hin, ja, das ist die Zeit, da war aber Bootstrap noch, noch einfach, da gab es noch
nicht so viel, hoffe ich mal, Range, Input, User Inputs, ne, nee, Forms muss ich wahrscheinlich
gucken, Range Slider, ja, genau, das will ich haben, allerdings, die schön gestylte
Bootstrap Variante, Range, gibt es nicht, ja, das ist natürlich blöd, Input, aber Input
habe ich schon gesucht, User Input, Input Groups, Extend Forms Basic Example, ok, Bootstrap
Input Range, das gab es damals bestimmt auch schon, Bootstrap 3, ja, Type Range, ja, das
kenne ich, wie, Moment, das gibt es den Slider, das ist nicht, ist das nicht eingebaut, Bootstrap
3 hatte den nicht, das ist natürlich doof, ich meine, wir können einfach einen Input
Feld machen, aber so ein Slider wäre schon, ein Slider wäre in dem Fall wahrscheinlich
irgendwie cooler, ich weiß nur, dass solche Sachen extrem eklig selbst zu stylen sind,
die sehen nämlich, guck mal, ich zeig sie mal, hier Chrome, ach Mist, da habe ich den
Gramm nicht, null, also, ich kann euch aber so mal hier zeigen, guck mal, Firefox, Chrome,
jetzt mal zum Vergleich, der Standard Slider, da und da, also die unterscheiden sich ja
so schon mal ein bisschen und Safari sieht nochmal anders aus, also man muss den quasi
Custom Style und sonstiges, so, Mindest Range 24, Maximum, ja, Maximum ist, Selected W-Lan,
da kommt Maximum einfach mal 60, das muss ich da noch, muss das, muss noch ordentlich
gemacht werden, so, und jetzt können wir hier, ne, Step 1, so, jetzt können wir nämlich
hier einstellen, wie lang das Ganze, wie viele Passwörter man sein, die haben die vielleicht
da eigene Klasse, das ist eine gute Frage, wo, wo, wo könnten die einen Slider verwenden?
Bei, Users, Access Point, W-Lan, vielleicht bei Passwort Länge auch, ne, ne, ne, ne,
die schreiben es einfach so rein, Applications, äh, und jetzt, Konsone, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,
Konsone, wo muss ich hin, Style Editor, oder, ja, Inspect, ah, da, da steht aber nichts
drin, Browser Styles, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert, das ist zu advanced
für mich, muss ich vielleicht die ganze Seite anklicken, oder so, ich mein, wir können,
wir können, ich, ich hab ne andere Idee, klicke jetzt einfach auf CSS, Slider, CSS,
Slider, ist das dreimal das gleiche eingebunden, oder was, Range, Input, Input Type, ne, ne,
ne, ich glaube die haben nichts, das HTML durchsuchen geht nicht, das ist ja alles dynamisch
aus JavaScript erstellt, also was, auf CLS und dann siehst du die Input Box, ne, ich
hab keine Ahnung, wohin, wo ich hier irgendwas machen soll, ah, add new class, achso, oh,
das ist ja durch die Brust ins Auge, Slide, Enter, ne, ne, das ist glaube ich, das ist
Range, Input, Input Group, Addon, row, ne, ich glaube die, ich glaube die haben sowas
nicht, naja gut, ich mein, wir können das, wir können das theoretisch auch, theoretisch
auch selbst ein, also was, was, was braucht man da so, also die Zahl neben dran wäre
auf jeden Fall schon mal net, net so verkehrt, so Randomize, dumm dumm dumm, das funktioniert
so, Slider, wo hab ich den Slider, so, der Slider soll, also wir brauchen das Ganze
hier auf jeden Fall nochmal, das HTML wird so schnell unübersichtlich, ich, ich geh
da überhaupt nicht mehr durch, Slider seit 5 Minuten oder so, Input Range, wir haben
das jetzt alles umgezogen auf Svelte, ok, so, so ist besser, busy, busy, busy lang das
Ganze aber ok, sollte das, sollte das jetzt nicht in, dahinter sein, wie krieg ich jetzt
hinter den Slider was Leute, boah CSS Zeug man, ich hab, ich hab ne Idee, so schon mal
nicht, man kann doch Flex, ich kann auch Flex machen oder, Flex und dann, ah Moment, das
ist ja nicht, wir sind ja hier nicht bei Tailwinter, Flex, ich bin zu dumm für das
noch eine Column machen, du meinst jetzt quasi nicht so, ach so ok, ok, also das hier quasi
nebeneinander und jetzt, dass man hier keine Ahnung, 2, sollte das jetzt nicht eigentlich
nebeneinander kommen, nebeneinander gehen, wie groß ist denn das Grit maximal von, ok,
Ok das ist in Ordnung und da kommt jetzt kein Input hin, sondern da kommt jetzt hier die
Länge hin.
Also hier, keine Ahnung, Passwort, irgendwie so keine Ahnung, okay, wirklich schick ist
das nicht.
Das sollte maximal so lang sein wie die Inputs, ansonsten sieht das mal richtig hängen geblieben
aus.
Also sagen wir mal Style oder machen wir einfach mal hier, haben wir hier 4 oder 5, äh 4, sieht
besser aus.
Aber hübsch ist was anderes oder was, nein nicht dass es was bringt.
Versucht ihr mal das Class FormControl zu geben.
Ah das ist jetzt FieldControl, mein FormControl gibt es hier gar nicht, oh das ist ja eklig
man.
Range, Class, FormControl, ne das interessiert nicht so wirklich, weil das ist schon, das
ist schon irgendwie in Ordnung, aber mir gefällt es ja nicht wirklich, also das mit dem Slider,
das mit dem Slider überlege ich mir nochmal, ich hätte jetzt ja gerne dahinter jetzt stehen,
also sagen wir mal, LED, irgendwie sowas, keine Ahnung, 24, das wird mir schon auch
viel zu unübersichtlich gerade, wir gucken jetzt mal kurz, ob man das zumindest den Kram
noch updaten kann.
Also hier muss dann an der Stelle rein, Gen, oh 24 und hier können wir Value oder Bind,
Bind, Value, ich kann Enter drücken kann, ist schrecklich, ja ok, das funktioniert.
Also das können wir zumindest schon mal einstellen.
An welcher Stelle würdest du Components machen, also wie würdest du das aufsplitten, ich meine,
man kann ja nicht, man kann ja nicht wirklich jede, jedes Ding hier als Component machen
oder, zumal das ganze Styling, Diff Zeug ja bleibt oder, ich meine, ob ich jetzt den Input
als Component habe, macht doch keinen Unterschied, also wie würde ich, wie würde ich es übersichtlicher
machen oder eine Form Component, das ist auch doof, wo du 3x HTML kopiert hast, ja das könnte
man tatsächlich machen, du meinst sowas hier, also zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel anstelle des
Inputs, dass das hier eine Component wäre, das da fürs Passwort eine und dann, ja das
könnte man, das könnte man echt machen, das ist wahrscheinlich, das ist dann tatsächlich
ein bisschen übersichtlicher, dann artet, dann artet das nicht so aus, ja, ja das ist, das
ist wahrscheinlich wirklich besser, da habt ihr recht, aber das kriege ich geistig heute
immer auf die Reihe, das ist mir zu viel Frontentzeuge auf einmal, ich muss jetzt was futtern erstmal,
chat ihr könnt es euch aussuchen, entweder, ich gehe jetzt, ok eigentlich weiß ich die
Antwort schon, ich wollte gerade sagen, entweder, ich gehe jetzt auf und futter was oder wir
gucken uns irgendwie noch eins, zwei Videos an und ich futter was dabei und gehe danach
auf, angucken, die bizarre vierte Konsole, was gucken wir uns denn an, guck mal mein eigenes
Video, null, aber das halt, das klingt doch gar nicht so schlecht, was wird uns denn heute
empfohlen, oh das habe ich lange nicht mehr geguckt, haben die überhaupt noch den coolen
Sprecher, ne ich futter nur Toastbrot, da kann ich mir gerade keine BBQ Pit Boys reinfahren
bei, Kokona Style, warum ist dein Browser auf 200% Zoom, dass man besser was sieht,
gibt ja auch Leute, die gucken vom Smartphone und so zu, ok dann kommen wir gucken uns jetzt
das an oder gibt es, gibt es irgendwelche, ok ich, irgendein Kochvideo, gibt es irgendwas,
was ihr da gerne guckt, irgendwas was zum Essen passt, kenne ich alle nicht, ich kenne
es nicht, ich kenne es nicht, ich kenne es nicht, ich kenne es auch nicht, ich kenne
Kein Stresskochen?
Was?
Brisket aus der...
Oh, das könnten ja bei den Barbecue Big Pit Boys kommen.
Kartoffelknödel mit Soße, okay, was?
Der perfekte Semmelknödel, ein illegales, kein Stress...
Ein günstiges Drei-Gänge-Weihnachts-Menü.
Der beste Döner für zu...
Auf geht's Leute, wir gucken uns jetzt an, wie Döner gemacht werden.
Die Wahrheit ist, wenn du ein gutes türkisches Grillhaus in der Nähe hast, macht es wenig
Sinn, einen Döner in den eigenen vier Wänden zu zaubern.
Das hält mir aber nicht davon ab, ein haushaltstaugliches Dönerrezept zu machen.
Und zwar so ziemlich alle Varianten und ohne Drehspäße.
Moment, bringen wir keine Bayer?
Das sind Österreicher, keine Bayer.
Euter, sagen bloß die Österreicher.
Euter.
Alter, ah, meine Ohren, was ist mit dem los?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Ist das die Nino Kuni Battle Musik?
Oder von was anderem, kommt mir übelst bekannt vor.
Ah, Smash, Smash, ich habe es irgendwie verwechselt, aber ja, kann sein.
Einfache Variante, geben wir zu 500 Gramm Mehl, ein Backel Hefe, ein dreiviertel Esslöffel
Salz oder nach Geschmack und 350 Milliliter lauwarmes Lachsauce.
Leute, ich esse mal was.
Deswegen empfiehlt sich der Rühraufsatz, knetet es mindestens 10 Minuten lang, damit
der Teig eine ordentliche Struktur kriegt.
Richtet euch gleich ein Bockblech mit Bockpapier her und mit geölten Fingern kurz den Teig
so ungefähr in Fladengröße.
Streut eine Sesam-Schwarzkümmelmischung drauf, drückt es ein bisschen fest.
So etwas hätte ich nicht bei daheim.
Und lasst den Teig für circa 1 Stunde lang an einem warmen Ort gehen.
Nach der Gehzeit dürft ihr euch wieder die Hände einösen.
Habt ihr Sesam-Schwarzkümmelmischung daheim?
Ölen.
Und mit euren Fingern diese Fladenbrot typischen Muster reindrücken.
Dann kommt alles bei 220°C für 15-17 Minuten in den Ofen.
Und fertig ist unser Low Effort Fladenbrot.
Ein uralter Dönerstandel Trick sind Döner Taschen.
Da wird einfach der Pizzateig genommen, den sie ja meistens sowieso schon haben und machen
damit die Brötchen.
Sie müssen nicht extra Brot kaufen und der Kunde kriegt immer frisches Brot.
Eine Win-Win Situation.
Also wir nehmen 500 Gramm Pizzamehl, wie zum Beispiel Tipo 00, 325 Milliliter Wasser,
ein halbes Backel Hefe beziehungsweise Gärme, 20 Gramm gutes Olivenöl und circa einen
dreiviertelten Esslöffel Salz.
Knete jetzt alles für...
Also nicht, dass ich das hier mal selbst machen würde oder so.
Mindestens 10 Minuten durch, bis ein geschmeidiger Teig entsteht.
Und gebt es ihm dann in ein gut geölteres und verschließbares Gefäß.
Der Teig soll auch mit Öl benetzt sein, damit er nicht eintrocknet.
Dann kommt der ganze Spaß für mindestens 12 Stunden in den Kühlschrank.
Glaubt mir, die lange Gehzeit, die macht ihr nämlich aus.
Bemehlt eure Arbeitsfläche und knetet den Teig auch mal ordentlich durch.
Messt euch Teigsegmente mit ca. 125 bis 130 Gramm aus und schleift euch daraus Kugeln.
Macht das mit dem gesamten Teig und am Ende sollten so 6 Kugeln rauskommen.
Gebt ein bisschen Mehl drüber und deckt das für ca. eine Dreiviertelstunde mit einem Geschirrtuch ab.
Die werden dann bei 250°C Umluft gebacken und dafür benutzt man Pizza-Stahn.
Weil die meisten Dönerläden einen Ofen mit Schamott-Stahn drinnen haben
und weil man bei den Temperaturen kein Backpapier verwenden soll, weil euch sonst die Bude abfackeln kann.
Als Workaround kann man ein verkehrtes Backblech nehmen.
Rollt eure Teigkugeln gleichmäßig zu einer Scheibe aus und schaut, dass die trockenere Seite unten ist.
Und für die, die keinen Pizzaschieber haben...
Das ist nicht bayerisch, das ist ein garantiert österreichisches Backblech.
Oder zumindest was flaches, feuerfestes, wo die Teiglinge runterrutschen können.
Alter, Backbleche sind echt die Antwort auf...
Nur Österreicher sagen Alter.
Alles.
Bei so hohen Temperaturen sind die maximal 5-7 Minuten im Ofen.
Die lange Gehzeit und die Temperatur lassen sich wunderschön aufgehen.
Und fertig ist eure perfekte Döner-Tasche.
Es fehlt noch mein Lieblingsfladenbrot Rezept.
Zu 500 Gramm Mehl kommen 300 Milliliter lauwarmes Wasser.
Haben wir jetzt nicht langsam genug Brot für Döner zu machen?
Muss man drei verschiedene Sorten Brot machen für den gleichen Döner oder?
3 Teelöffel 10%iger Joghurt, 1 Esslöffel Olivenöl, 1 ¾ Esslöffel Salz oder halt noch belieben.
Und ein Packerl Trockenhefe bzw. Germ.
Knetet den Burschen für ca. 10 Minuten oder bis er sich von der Seite löst.
Lasst ihn dann für ¾ Stunde an einem warmen Ort gehen.
Danach dürft ihr ihn auf eurer bemehlten Oberfläche lösen.
Ich glaube wir sind noch bei Schritt 1. Er zeigt uns einfach 3 verschiedene Arten, wie man das Brot für den Döner machen kann.
Wahrscheinlich ist der Döner selbst nicht so kompliziert und da hat er halt noch 3 Brotrezepte reingepackt.
Also richtig durchkneten und eine Kugel formen.
Und wenn ihr mich fragt, was ein Life Hack für effizientes Teig ausrollen ist,
dann ist die Antwort natürlich ein verkehrtes Backblech.
Alter Backbleche sind so ultra.
Wir nehmen die Rückseite ganz einfach, weil sich der Teig da leicht ausrollen lässt.
Aber davor muss er noch ein bisschen entspannen.
Deshalb lassen wir ihn 20-30 Minuten ruhen, damit er uns später keinen Hack mehr macht.
Nach der Ruhezeit wieder beheben und gleich den Seht ausrollen.
Da wir schlauen Füchse die Rückseite vom Backblech verwenden, haben wir keine Kanten.
Somit können wir ohne Probleme ausrollen.
Wie beim ersten Rezept habt ihr auch dort die Möglichkeit,
an mir gibt es Toastbrot,
könnt mit euren Fingern, diesmal ungeölt, das Fladenbrotmuster rein zu drucken.
Und jetzt kommt der nächste Life Hack.
Nein, es hat nichts mit Backblechen zu tun, sondern mit einer Sprühflasche.
Die hat mir exakt einen Euro gekostet und leistet mir schon seit mehreren Jahren sehr gute Dienste.
Nicht nur beim Schnitzel machen, sondern auch beim Backen.
Ich sprühe da das Fladenbrot gerne mit Wasser ein.
Das kenne ich, sowas ähnliches hat meine Oma auch gemacht.
Wie der Sesam und Schwarzkümmel drauf geht.
Da hält das Zeug besser.
Und ich glaube manchmal macht man das auch, wenn es einfach noch ein bisschen brauner werden soll.
Ein bisschen fest drucken nicht vergessen.
Seid zärtlich.
Und dann noch einmal einsprühen.
Und so kommt der Fladen bei 220°C Umluft für 15-17 Minuten in den Ofen.
Das Wasser sorgt dafür, dass die Oberfläche unglaublich knusprig wird.
Das eigene Fladenbrot zu backen ist halt eine Ehrenkoch Sache.
Weil in Wirklichkeit kaufen kann man es natürlich auch.
Okay gut, einen Döner kann man ja auch häufig erwerben.
Alter!
Ich meine, Alter, was soll denn das?
Was passiert jetzt?
Es gibt natürlich viele Möglichkeiten sein Fleisch zu grillen.
Auf einem Gasgrill zum Beispiel oder klassisch auf Holzkohle.
Richtig fein ist, wenn man so einen Keramikbrenner hat.
Da kriegt man richtig schön Röstaromen drauf.
Auf der Herdplatte gibt es auch Variante, damit man dieses Grillaroma kriegen kann.
Dazu braucht man Pfanne, die man hoch erhitzen kann.
Wie zum Beispiel Edelstahl oder Guss-Eisen.
Da fallen Beschichtete, wenn sie nicht extra dafür ausgelegt sind, leider meistens weg.
Am nächsten bin ich an das Grillaroma, bis jetzt mit einer Guss-Eisen geriffelt.
So etwas habe ich tatsächlich, benutze ich aber nie.
Die hat richtig schön Tiefe Rillen und kann dadurch, dass sie aus Guss-Eisen ist, extrem heiß gemacht werden.
Was wie schon erwähnt mit einer Beschichteten nicht möglich ist.
Natürlich wird das Fleisch von einem Drehspieß wesentlich besser.
Da musst du halt immer für eine ganze Fußballmannschaft kochen, damit sie es auszuhalten.
Aber ich denke, wir können...
Es sei denn, man hat das Gerät.
...schmacklich schon gut in die Richtung.
Fürs erste machen wir mal Hühnchen und dafür nehmen wir ausgelöste Oberkeulen.
Ich meine gut, du kannst natürlich auch Brust nehmen und bei normaler moderater Hitze in einer Beschichteten braten.
Das schmeckt klarerweise auch gut.
Aber wenn ihr den Dönerfleisch Geschmack haben wollt, dann braucht ihr die Oberkeule.
Ansonsten könnt ihr mir nämlich glauben, in so einem Dönerspieß wird sehr wenig Brust zu finden sein.
Also salzt die Oberkeulen ordentlich ein, gebt zwei Teelöffel Paprika dazu.
Ich glaube eh, dass die meisten Dönerspieße irgendwelche Abfallprodukte aus der Fleischproduktion sind.
Und jetzt nicht irgendwie so was super hochwertiges, sondern irgendwelche Reste, die werden einfach gepresst zu irgendeinem Dönerspieß und fertig.
Und zwei Teelöffel Kreuzkümmel.
Das klingt jetzt wenig, aber der größte Feind von selbstgemachten Döner ist über Würzen.
Es ist ja wie immer euch selbst überlassen.
Vielleicht kennt ihr diese pelzigen Hühnerstücke, die das Resultat von einer zu gut gemeinten Applikation von Fertig Döner Gewürzmischungen sind.
Das wollen wir auf jeden Fall nicht.
Übrigens reibe ich da noch zwei Knoblauchzehen dazu.
Und eine halbe Zwiebel für den Geschmack und damit das Fleisch ein bisschen weicher wird.
Das war die Grundmischung und wenn ihr dann noch getrockneten Oregano, getrockneten Thymian oder was was ihr noch dazugeben wollt, fühlt es euch frei.
Alles zusammen kommt dann für vier Stunden oder am besten über Nacht in den Kühlschrank.
Wenn ihr es gleich verwenden wollt, ja dann tut ihr es.
Aber glaubt ihr, das macht einen großen Unterschied.
Ich mache immer gleich mehr und friere mir das dann portionsweise ein, damit ich immer ein bisschen Dönerfleisch zur Hand habe.
Hilft sogar geschmacklich ein bisschen Wein. Dönerspieße sind ja bekanntlich immer eingefroren.
Das Ganze geht natürlich auch mit Laum.
Ich empfehle da Stücke aus der Schulter bzw. aus der Keule.
Ansonsten ist das Prozedere das gleiche.
Ihr solltet halt nur schauen, dass ihr je nachdem wie ihr das Fleisch verwendet, auch die richtige Größe schneidet.
Die aus dem alten Video bekannte Dönerbudendöner Variante darf natürlich auch nicht fehlen.
Dazu brauchen wir Faschiertes, ihr habt da Lammfleisch, ihr könnt natürlich ein Rindfleisch nehmen.
Der Fettgehalt sollte 20% sein. Am besten sogar noch mehr.
Das Geheimnis da ist die Bindung.
Ich will jetzt aber mal gucken, wie der Döner am Ende aussieht.
Jetzt könnt ihr euch sicher sein, in den meisten billig ist der Sämpfmehl und Stärkung gut.
Jetzt dürft ihr eure Döner Schneide Skills unter Beweis stellen.
Nehmt das Schraubengenäht und schneidet euch die Fleischscheiben runter.
Am besten so dünn wie möglich.
Wahrscheinlich wisst ihr schon, was der nächste Schritt ist.
Ihr braucht jetzt nämlich nur mehr die Fleischscheiben in einer heißen Pfanne anbraten.
Es ist echt interessant, wie nah der Geschmack an die Dönerspieße kommt, die nur mit Faschierten gemacht sind.
Und ehrlich, das ist wesentlich besser, als wie das Zeug, das du im Supermarkt zum kaufen kriegst.
Außerdem ist es gut, sowas immer griffbereit im Gefrierschrank zu haben.
Und jetzt kümmern wir uns ums andere Fleisch.
Heizt euren Ofen auf 150°C Ober-Unterhitze vor, ebenfalls die Pfanne.
Wie gesagt, die muss richtig richtig heiß sein.
Grillt die Fleischstücke von beiden Seiten richtig scharf an.
Und da geht es eigentlich nur darum, dass man die Röstaromen kriegt.
Ich will wissen, wie das Ding am Ende ausschaut.
Boah, da bist du aber ohne Scheiß, wenn du das machst, bist du 2 Stunden für den Döner beschäftigt, oder?
Es gibt leider sehr wenig Dönerläden, die das bei sich haben.
Aber macht das mal, das scheißelte Gemüse.
Also im Gefrierschrank Fleisch, ich glaube, ich habe noch ein bisschen Hähnchen oder so.
Einen Esslöffel Tomatenmark, Zitronen,
Zuck Sachen falsch ausgesprochen, sorry an alle Döner.
Rosen schaffen und fertig.
Doch, wie sieht der Döner aus?
Es fehlt aber noch etwas wichtiges.
Und zwar die Summe und haben dann einen Kraut-Zwiebelsalat.
Was für unsere Zwecke perfekt passt.
Jetzt kommt der Döner.
Wie ihr euren Döner macht, könnt ihr jetzt komplett selbst entscheiden.
Passt es einfach die Rezepte an euren Geschmack an.
Und ihr werdet sehen, es zeigt sich aus.
Du kannst wahrscheinlich daheim erst mal 20 Döner machen.
Und wieder die Dinge selbst in die Hand zu nehmen.
Das, was sich gewisse Döner buden, als Döner verkaufen trauen,
schafft ihr mittellinx daheim und das wesentlich besser.
Außerdem, was gibt es schöneres als ein gepflegtes Glaserlei rein
und am Döner, von dem ihr mit Stolz behaupten könnt, dass ihr den komplett selber gemacht habt.
Jetzt müssen wir auch immer Döner machen.
Also wenn ich echt nur mal zwei Tage Zeit habe fürs Mittagessen,
dann mache ich einen Döner.
Nee, ist mir viel zu anstrengend.
Ach ja, passt natürlich auch sehr sinnvoll.
Guck mal hier, kein Stress kochen, der beste Döner.
Alternativ können wir uns die besten Velociraptor-Scenes aus Jurassic Park angucken.
Was ist denn das für ein Döner?
Der Rest, hier irgendwie was essen, jetzt kommt auf einmal ein Dinosaurier zwischendurch.
Das ergibt ja so gar keinen Sinn, YouTube-Mann.
Na, wie dem auch sein.
Okay, Leute, vielleicht bauen wir das nächste Mal tatsächlich noch mal weiter.
Weil es war jetzt genug JavaScript, aber ich muss jetzt MMO-Kreiselgrind machen gleich.
Wer weiß, was YouTube sich denkt.
Wir sehen uns, ich gehe jetzt erstmal auf.
Bis dann, macht's gut, see you.